HEARING OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE --
SO TODAY WE HAVE -- SIXTEEN
BILLS ON THE AGENDA -- ONE OF
THE BILLS IN TODAY'S AGENDA AB --
ONE SIXTY EIGHT WE ARE PULLING
IT WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY -- IT
WILL BE HEARD AT OUR NEXT
SCHEDULED HEARING ON JULY
SECONDS -- IN ADDITION THREE OF
THE BILLS ARE GOING TO BE ON
CONSENT THOSE ARE AB.
THREE FORTY NINE AB.
THREE NINETY THREE AND AB --
TWELVE NINETY IN ADDITION -- FOR
WHAT WE'RE REQUESTING -- WHEN
WE'RE WITNESSES TESTIFYING AT
THE TABLE -- IS TO PLEASE LIMIT
THE TESTIMONY TO EITHER THREE
MINUTES APIECE IF YOU HAVE TO
WITNESSES.
OR TWO MINUTES APIECE IF YOU
HAVE. FIVE THREE WITNESSES.
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM I
THINK WE'RE ONE SHORT -- AND SO
WE WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM ONE
ANOTHER MEMBER ARRIVED SO FOR
NOW WE'LL START.
AS A SUB COMMITTEE -- WITH THAT --
WE'RE GOING FILE ORDER AND I
WILL ASK OUR MYSTERY TING -- TO
COME UP TO PRESENT -- NUMBER --
ONE ARE THE FIRST ITEM ON THE
AGENDA AB.
SIXTY EIGHT AND THEN AFTER THAT
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TWO AB --
SIXTY NINE SO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- LET ME FIRST JUST THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN YOURSELF
FOR WORKING ON OUR BILL BE
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS -- AS YOU
KNOW EIGHTY USE ARE A CRITICAL
COMPONENT TO HOW WE RESOLVE THIS
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE OVER THE OVER
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE --
THIS BILL.
TRIES TO BUILD ON SENATOR Y.
CASKETS LEGISLATION TO REALLY.
DO MORE STREAMLINING -- AS YOU
ALL KNOW AFTER SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE KEEP PASSED LEGISLATION ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE NUMEROUS
CITIES DECIDED TO FIND MORE AND
AROUND -- THAT LEGISLATION IN TO
PASS A DIFFERENT PIECES LITTLE
PIECES OF LOCAL ORDINANCES THAT
WOULD BASICALLY -- BEAR AND
EIGHTY YEARS SO -- YOU KNOW JUST
JUST ONE QUICK EXAMPLES THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO LOCAL EDU
ORDINANCE WHICH ONLY ALLOWS
HOMEOWNERS STABILITY TO USE ON
LOTS ARE EIGHT THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET OR GREATER.
SO OUR BILLAB SIXTY EIGHT
REMOVES MANY OF REMOVES THAT
BARRIER PLUS MANY OTHERS. TO
STREAMLINED THE CONSTRUCTION OF
EIGHTY YEARS -- AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE SUPPORT ALL
THE WORK ON THIS BILL WE WILL
TURN OVER TO OUR FIRST WITNESS I
THANK YOU AND I'D.
SOME MEMBERS JUST TO CLARIFY THE
AMENDMENTS -- WORKED ARE YOU --
YOU CROSSED AS AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
ARE IN PRINT THERE WILL BE NO
FURTHER AMENDMENTS TODAY TO
ASSIST.
THE MEASURE RUNS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS --
MY NAME'S LOUIS BRONTE I'M WITH
CALIFORNIAN BE A CALIFORNIA BE
REPRESENTS THOUSANDS OF YOU MS
ACOSTA ST WE WERE WITH DOZENS OF
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT.
ADVOCATE FOR MORE HOMES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AS A WAY TO FIGHT
DISPLACEMENT AND FIGHT RAISING
RENTS -- WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY EIGHT TODAY BECAUSE IT
FURTHER STREAMLINES THE THE
IMPORTANT EIGHTY LEGISLATION THE
STATE HAS ALREADY ENACTED.
IN PLACES LIKE LA WE'VE SEEN A
1000% INCREASES IN THE NUMBER OF
EIGHTY IN PERMITS.
BECAUSE OF THE EFFICACY OF THIS
LEGISLATION BUT SOME COMMUNITIES
LIKE PIEDMONT -- CONTINUE TO
RESIST AND AND AND SUBVERT A
STATE LAW ON EIGHTIES AND SO
THIS CLOSE TO SOME OF THOSE
LOOPHOLES -- I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MADE A REALLY
GOOD PITCH FOR AT AB SIXTY EIGHT
HAPPENING ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS BUT OTHER THAN THAT
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OKAY FIVE THANK YOU IN BEFORE WE
GO ANY FURTHER WE'RE GONNA STOP
WAS A QUORUM WOULD YOU PLEASE --
CALL THE MEMBERS.
SENATOR WIENER PRESIDENT WIENER
PRESENT MORROW.
HERE ARE ALL PRESENT BATES.
BATES PRESENT CAMARO.
CARILLO PRESENT DRAWS -- MCGUIRE
MORE LOOK.
MORE LIKE PRESENT ROUGH.
PROF PRESENT SKINNER UMBERG
CASKEY BECAUSE HE PRESENT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
HI.
THANK YOU MISTER REDDICK HI
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTER OF COMMON
PLEASE SAY YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION -- THANK YOU.
REVEREND TURN MEMBERS FEEL LIKE
EVER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND
SUPPORT.
BUT AFTERNOON MIKE MCLAUGHLIN
VOLUNTEER WITH A A RP IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS SO
IT'S A MATTER NOT LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MICHAEL EMISORA CONDO AT HOME IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ALFA WITH THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
SILVIO FROM YOU HAVE A FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT.
TôI DAVID BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION AND SUPPORT.
HE TO ROUTE ENTERPRISE COMEY
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH LONG ON BEHALF OF AND
HE'S IN A BAG AND SUPPORT.
AND YOUR MUSE FRAZIER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
RICHARD MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MOST ORDER ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TONY BE WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT.
SERVICE ONLY SHAUN BEHALF OF
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI INSTRUCTS SUPPORT
THANKS.
NOR IN THE NEAR THE TWO HUNDRED
AND SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
OKAY THREE NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD OR OR
TWEENER.
PATCH ABOUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MINISTRY UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT WE DID EXPRESSED
CONCERNS THE AUTHOR AND ADD THEM
AT LANGUAGES INCLUDING
AMENDMENTS WE APPRECIATE THAT.
THERE IS ONE DRAFTING ISSUE THAT
WORKING WORK WITH THE STAFF ON
LOOK FOR TO RESOLVING THAT THE
NEXT POLICY COMMITTEE SO THANK
YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT.
ARE ANY OTHER TWEENER IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- SEE NINE WE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OUR MOTION BY CENTER ROTH ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS -- THE ITEM --
AND SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL AND FOR OTHER --
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS AROUND
EIGHTY USE -- WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH US CENTER
SKINNER AND ALSO -- CENTER WHY
CAL SKI ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
IT'S A GOOD TEAM EFFORT -- I YOU
KNOW IT IT'S I I WILL SAY IT'S
AND I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE I
WON'T SAY FOR EVERY EIGHTY YOU
BILL TODAY BUT ALSO AT ONCE.
IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING THAT IT'S
BEEN ABOUT ALMOST FORTY YEARS.
SINCE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PASSED A LAW SAYING THAT CITIES
MUST ALLOW YOU TO USE PERIOD END
OF STORY -- HERE WE ARE ALMOST
FORTY YEARS LATER AND WE HAVE TO
HAVE A CONTINUING SERIES OF
BILLS -- TO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE
AFTER LOOPHOLE AND IT'S A GAME
OF CAT AND MOUSE.
AND THERE ARE MORE MORE CITIES
THAT ARE HAVING PER ARM BRACING
EIGHTY USE -- AND DOWN THE STAY
AND AND THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
CLOSE -- THE STATE'S MULTI
MILLION -- HOME SHORTAGE -- BUT
TOO MANY CITIES CONTINUE. TO PUT
THESE OBSTACLES IN PLACE LIKE
OUTRAGEOUS FEES OR SOME OF THE
SIZE OF RESTRICTIONS AND SO ON
AND SO FORTH -- AND SO I I I
COMMEND YOU ON ON YOUR WORK ON
THIS ISSUE AND IT JUST DOESN'T
JOINED AYE RECOMMENDATIONS --
WE'VE MOTION FROM SENATOR ROTH
AND CITY NOTATIONAL -- DESIRES
TO SPEAK -- WE WILL CALL.
ME MY CLOTHES WELL I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO STATE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT AND WORK ON
THIS AS WELL.
I THINK WE GIVE ME HOPE IS WHAT
DENNIS RON TO TALK ABOUT WITH
THE CITY OF LA IS THAT ONCE
THOUGHT.
THE SHOCK OF CAME AWFULLY SAW LA
A START TO PROSPER AND THAT'S
WHAT WE REALLY HOPE WITH THIS
LEGISLATION SO WITHOUT RESPECT
FOR US RIGHT.
OKAY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ON THE BILL SIXTY EIGHT
BY SOME REMEMBER CHIANG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI MORRELL.
WELL I BATES.
KERO.
KERO AYE DORADO.
MCGUIRE.
MORE LOCK.
ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
CASKEY.
HI KATHY I OKAY THE VOTERS FIVE
ZERO WILL PUT IT ON CALL. FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU AN
ARGUMENT OUT PURSUE THE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWO AB.
SIXTY NINE THANK YOU AB SIXTY
NINTH ANOTHER EIGHTY YOU BILL --
THIS PAST THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO DEVELOP A SMALL
HOME BUILDINGS COAT BY A
PARTICULAR WERE FINDING WITH.
SOME OF THE SMALLER UNITS HAVING
A CO SPECIFICALLY.
GIVING GUIDANCE TO SMALL KITCHEN
SMALL BATHROOM SMALL APPLIANCES.
WE THINK THIS WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL.
IN ALSO -- SPRING EIGHTY YOU
CONSTRUCTION WITHOUT RESPECT
FAST.
FIVE TERRIFIC A MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS LOSE BONTA AGAIN WITH
CALIFORNIAN BE HI THIS IS A
RELATIVELY TECHNICAL BILL -- BUT
A VERY IMPORTANT ONE COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE WILL OFTEN
REQUIRE EIGHTY USED TO PROVIDE
COMMENSURATE APPLIANCES OR
COMPLIANCE IS COMMENSURATE WITH
WHAT THEY WOULD REQUIRE OF THAT
STANDARD.
SINGLE FAMILY HOME AT THAT
CAMINO WATER HEATER THAT IS GOOD
FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR OR
DISHWASHER FOR THE SAME THIS
ALLOWS -- A CD TO WORK WITH A
BUNCH OF STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP
GUIDELINES THAT ALLOW FOR
SMALLER CLIENTS IS THAT MORE FIT --
THE THE SMALL NATURE OF EIGHTY
IS IN ORDER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND SOME MEMBER YOU
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS YES
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
DOES IT MATTER THAT LIFE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DEREK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL I WAS THE CONDO AT HOME
STRONG SUPPORT.
MIKE MCLAUGHLIN AARP SUPPORTS.
MOST OR NORTH THE SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THE ONLY BE WITH THE A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SO SHE'S IN
HER SUPPORT.
SYLVIA FOR ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT.
TODAY THE BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION SUPPORT.
BACK ALONG AND TO SEE A BAG IN
SUPPORT.
THE ROW ENTERPRISE CAN YOU
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
PATRICK OUT ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
ANDREW MS FISHER WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
MY KITCHEN MAYES ON BEHALF OF
THE TWO HUNDRED AND SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
OKAY IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
CAREFREE BUT THE COMMITTEES
CENTER ROTH HAS MOVED -- THE
BILL COLLEAGUES OF OR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
DO SENATOR BATES -- I NOTICED
THERE WAS AN ISSUE WITH THE FIRE
SAFETY AND I WONDERED IF THE
AUTHOR HAD ADDRESS THAT.
WITH THE FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
A PARTICULAR CONCERN THAT I HAD
IS THE WILD LAND.
INTERFACE THE AND CERTAINLY LOT
COVERAGE ON SOME OF THESE WHEN
YOU'RE ON NO LONGER LOOKING AT
ZONING REQUIREMENTS.
AND ACCESS TO LOTS.
WHEN YOU HAVE FIRES AND
CERTAINLY ON THEIR PROXIMITY TO
THOSE HOMES THAT ARE NEXT TO
THEM?
HI IF CERTAINLY I THINK A
CONCERN OF FIVE FOR FIRE SAFETY
AND I WONDERED IF YOU HAVE BEEN.
LISTENING AND ADDRESSING THEIR
CONCERNS ON THAT I THINK BELIEVE
ON MY STAFF JUST MENTION TO ME
THEIR MAIN CONCERN WAS REGARDING
THE POPULATION GROWTH IN THE
PROXIMITY.
TO HOUSING OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE THIS
WOULD INCREASE DENSITY WE ARE
SUPPORTER OF THAT -- OBVIOUSLY
IF THEY HAD -- SPECIFIC NEED A
MORE SPECIFIC CONCERNS OR
MOMENTS THAT THEY WANTED TO
BRING FORWARD WE WOULD BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO LISTEN TO THEM AT
THIS POINT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THEY HAVE.
A PRODUCT THAT FORMER.
TO BEEN SPECIFIC YEAH YES SO I
THINK IF THEY WOULD.
YOUR SAY HEY WE WOULD LIKE THIS
IN THE BILL ABOUT IN THE BILL
THEY QUIT THE MORE THAN HAPPY.
TO OF COURSE LISTEN TO THE
MAJORITY.
YEAH AND I AND WE DID RECEIVE.
THAT LETTER -- I DID REVIEW IT
AND I HAVE.
TO ASSIST ON THE LOS POLITICS
AND THE AUTHOR I I WAS REALLY
PERPLEXED BY THIS BILL THE BILL
PROVIDE EARLY SEASON BY THE SOME --
LETTER THE LETTER PROVIDES NO
SPECIFICS ABOUT WHAT -- THEY
WANT WHICH IS SAYS THIS IS A LOT
MORE HOUSING AND POPULATION AND
THAT MAKES IT HARDER FOR FIRE
FIGHTING OF COURSE WE NEED.
TO ADEQUATELY FUND FIRE SERVICES
BUT THE REALITY IS CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN EXPOSED GROWING POPULATION
WE NEED ENOUGH HOUSING.
THIS IS AN ARGUMENT AGAINST
ADDING ANY NEW HOUSING SO.
IT'S A PROBLEMATIC LETTER -- SO
YEAH.
I I JUST BROUGHT IT UP BUT
CHAIRMAN BECAUSE WE'VE HAD A
COUPLE I THINK JUST IN THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS WHERE THE
PROXIMITY OF ONE HOUSE TO
ANOTHER THAT CAUGHT FIRE.
ACTUALLY ENGAGE THOUGHT THE
OTHER PROPERTIES -- PART OF
ZONING IN OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE TO DO IS SET BACK FROM THE
SET BACKS HAVE MORE TO DO IT.
ACCESS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY THAN
THEY DO FOR YOU KNOW THE AND
MINORITIES THAT ARE THERE SO
IT'S SOMETHING THAT REALLY NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED WITH ALL THE
EIGHTY YOU -- LEGISLATION ON MY
TWO CONCERNS ARE CERTAINLY THAT
AND I THINK I'VE BEEN PRETTY
PRETTY WELL KNOWN. FOR MY
CONCERN ABOUT PARKING ISSUES SO
I AM LAYING OFF ALL THESE BILLS
TO SEE WHICH ONE FINALLY ALL
COMES TOGETHER BUT I DON'T THINK
WE CAN DENY.
WHAT IS BEEN TRADITIONAL IN
TERMS OF ZONING THAT HAS MORE TO
DO WITH PUBLIC SAFETY THEY ON?
YOU KNOW THE THE ACCOUTREMENT
FUNNY ON THE ARCHITECTURAL
FEATURES ON THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT CERTAINLY.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE SPENT
MAYBE TOO MUCH TIME ON DESIGN
REVIEW BUT WHEN YOU'RE DOING
PUBLIC SAFETY REVIEW AND YOU
LOOK AT WHAT HOW THESE --
PLANNERS ORIGINALLY SET FOR
ZONING REQUIREMENTS THEY HAD A
LOT TO DO WITH PUBLIC SAFETY AND
I'D I DON'T WANT US TO MISS THAT
AS WE LOOK AT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS WHICH I THINK IS A POSITIVE
I'M NOT SAYING THAT HE TO USE OR
NOT I THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE GOOD.
BUT I CAN CALL IN LAGUNA BEACH
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE INCORPORATED
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY THEY HAD
MANY GRANNY FLAT FOOTED MEET --
PUBLIC SAFETY STANDARDS THE WAY
THEY WERE HOOKED UP FOR A LOT --
FOR ENERGY AND ALL OF THAT AND
LET US NOT LOSE THAT WHEN THERE
ARE LOOKING AT BUILDING
STANDARDS SOMEONE YOU HAVE THE
FIRE CHOOSE BRING ENOUGH IT JUST
STRUCK ME THAT.
IS THAT WHAT THEY'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEY HAVEN'T BEEN SPECIFIC
SO I THINK I'M IN A SUPPORT THIS.
ONE BUT PUT OUT THERE THAT THEY
NEED TO BE SPECIFIC ABOUT THE
CONCERNED BECAUSE THEN WE WILL
NEED TO LOOK AT THE ZONING
REQUIREMENTS AND GIVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO THAT.
AND IT I THINK I CAN FIGURE THE
MEMBERS WE TOOK IN THIS
COMMITTEE ALSO ASKED AT T. TO
ADDRESS HEALTH AND SAFETY YEAH --
CONCERNS AS WELL SO -- WE WOULD
HOPE THAT THE PARTIES WERE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO TALK TO THEM AND
IF NOT THEY HAVE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TALK TO EACH CITY AS
THEY'RE REVIEWING THIS.
THANK YOU AND I JUST DONE
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS CENTER
BATES ONE OTHER THING TO KEEP IN
MIND IT'S A WHEN COMMUNITIES --
SUPPRESS EIGHTY USE DAY GET BILL
ANYWAY AND THEY'RE ILLEGAL --
AND SO THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY
INSPECTED OR OR COMPLY WITH THE
CODES -- AND SO -- ONE OF THE
GOALS HERE IS TO TRY TO BRING
EVERYTHING INTO THE SUNLIGHT --
AND HAVE AND HAVE THE SAFETY
THAT I KNOW WE BOTH WANT SOME.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
OKAY SEEING NINE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECT PRESS.
FOR THANK YOU -- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR ROTH AND WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY NINE
BY SOMEONE NUMBER CHIANG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
WE'RE FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER
AYE WIENER AYE MORAL.
MORRELL AYE BATES BATES AYE
CAMARO.
CAMARO I DRAWS A MCGUIRE MORE
LOCK.
MY LOOK I ROUGH.
ROUGH I SKINNER.
UMBERG LOOK OWSKI BECAUSE HE I
SEVEN VOTES WHICH IS AN APPLE
OKAY -- PUT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HEY I SEE THAT I SOME MEMBER
BLOOM IS HERE WHO HAS -- TWO
BILLS TODAY ONE THE THIRD IS ON
CONSENT.
SOME CONTENT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
WHICH ONE IS IT.
ON CONSENT SENATOR.
MISTER CHAIR.
TOLD NINETY SOME CONCERNS.
NO NO THAT'S GLORIA I'M SORRY.
THAT'S RIGHT YEAH I'M SORRY MY
APOLOGIES -- ALL -- THREE YOU'LL
NEED 2% TODAY.
OKAY -- SO WE'LL START WITH ITEM
NUMBER TEN A. B. E..
EIGHTY ONE PERFECT -- CARRYING
ON THE THEME OF ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS AND TO I JUST
WANNA OPEN BY SAYING HOW PROUD I
AM AND I KNOW SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE KEY -- BILLS THE SAME WAY
OF BEING THE TO AUTHORS OF THE
ORIGINAL LADY LEGISLATION THIS
IS SO WE KNEW IT WAS GOING TO
CATCH ON BOTH -- WE DIDN'T
REALLY KNOW I THINK AT THAT TIME --
JUST HOW MUCH THE IDEA WAS GONNA
RESONATE WITH CALIFORNIANS THAT
WE NOW KNOW THAT THERE ARE MANY
MANY THOUSANDS OF UNITS THAT
HAVE BEEN BUILT.
AS A RESULT OF THAT ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION SO -- AND A FURTHER
TO YOUR COMMENTS EARLIER MISTER
CHAIR -- I WANT TO ASSURE YOU
THAT -- WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
KEY -- AND TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING TIM -- MAKE SURE THAT --
ALL THESE BILLS ARE LANDED IN A
WAY THAT.
IS APPROPRIATE MIKE -- BILLS AT
DOES SERVE SEVERAL THINGS A
PERSON CLARIFIES THEM
DEFINITIONS AND REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING THE DEFINITION OF
PUBLIC TRANSIT -- WHEN EIGHTY IS
DISTANCE CAN BE FROM TRANSIT AND
THE TYPES OF EXISTING STRUCTURES
THAT CAN BE CONVERTED TO EIGHTY
YEARS SECONDLY?
IT REMOVES PROVISIONS THAT HAVE
GIVEN CITIES AND REASONABLY
BROAD DISCRETION FOR DENYING
EIGHTY YOU PERMITS AND FINALLY
IT REMOVES THE OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENT IN THE EXISTING
STATUTE WHICH IS.
UNFAIRLY SUBJECTED EIGHTY USED
TO A REQUIREMENT THAT DOESN'T
EXIST FOR ANY OTHER TYPE OF
HOUSING.
COULD RESULT IN EIGHTY IS BEING
DEMOLISHED AND IT CREATES LONG
TERM UNCERTAINTY AROUND THE
UNITS FUTURE AFTER IT'S BEEN
BUILT.
THE FIVE YEAR SUNSET -- TO THAT
PARTICULAR PROVISION WAS --
ADDED TO GIVE THE LEGISLATURE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE ITS
IMPACT -- AND SO AB EIGHT EIGHT
ONE IS HERE TO HELP PAY TO USE
REALIZE THEIR FULL POTENTIAL AS
THE OTHER OF BILLS TO AS WELL.
AND TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR HAVE FOR
LOOSE BRONTE FROM CALIFORNIA EMB
TO SPEAK MORE ON THE NEED FOR
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
LUIS MONTERO CALIFORNIAN BE -- I
THINK AB -- EIGHT EIGHT ONE IS
IMPORTANT AS IMPORTANT POLICY
STEP FOR THE LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE FOR THE SAME
REASONS THAT.
I AB SIXTY EIGHT AND SIXTY NINE
ARE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY PERHAPS THIS
BILL ELIMINATES THE OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS OR OR THE
ALLOWANCE FOR FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO IMPOSE AN
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENT -- WE'VE
HEARD FROM HOMEOWNERS AROUND THE
STATE THAT THAT OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENT CAN BE A BIG BARRIER
TO OBTAINING FINANCING AND IT'S
JUST ANOTHER HURDLE FOR THEM TO
CEAR.
UP BANKS ARE RELUCTANT WE'VE
SEEN TO LAND -- WHEN THERE'S
GOING TO BE A DEED RESTRICTION
THAT COMPLICATES THINGS AND AND
THEY SORT OF HAVEN'T YET FIGURED
OUT HOW TO HANDLE THAT -- AND SO
REMOVING THE ON OCCUPANCY YOU A
REQUIREMENT FOR FIVE YEARS.
TO SEE YOU SEE HOW SEE SEE HOW
THAT CLEARS UP THE MARKET A
LITTLE BIT -- IS GOING TO BE A
VERY POSITIVE STEP FORWARD --
JUST SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL.
WILL COME.
WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT.
MY CLAIM IS SO THE COMBO AT HOME
IN SUPPORT.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
TODAY THE BAY AREA HOUSING OUT
TO SEE COALITION SUPPORT.
GET THE ROW ENTERPRISE CUNY
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
TURNING BUT WE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HERE
SUPPORT.
THAT MARIN ERIN READING
ASSOCIATES SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
SO THE MATTER THAT WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS PART.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NONE WERE ABOUT THE
COMMITTEES CENTER ROTH HAS MOVED.
OF THE BILL ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS COLLEAGUES. FOR I THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS SO THIS IS
ACTUALLY.
QUITE IMPORTANT AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
IS AN IS REQUIREMENTS ARE
IMPOSED ON ANY OTHER KINDS OF
HOUSING.
AND FRANKLY IT'S A ANTI RENTER --
TO TO HAVE THESE KINDS OF
REQUIREMENTS AND 40% OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE RENTERS -- AND
WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE ADAM.
STOP PRETENDING THAT EVERYONE ON
SERRANO NOT EVERYONE DOES SO.
I THANK YOU FOR THIS AND THIS
DOESN'T TO A HIGH RECOMMENDATION.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER OPTION
ACOSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND HE
LIMITATION THE CRITERIA THAT THE
LOCALS AGENCIES COULD BE ABLE TO
USE TO LIMIT THE PLACEMENT.
JUST HAD A CONVERSATION ABOUT.
FIRE SAFETY -- IT INCLUDES WATER
SEWER SERVICES TRAFFIC FLOW.
IN PUBLIC SAFETY.
CAN YOU WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHTS ON
ON THIS.
EVOLVING ISSUE OF HAVING EIGHTY
USED IN THE WE WE AND THAT MAY
COMPOUND THE POTENTIAL FIRE
DANGER BY HAVING THAT.
IT ADDITIONAL DENSITY.
I THINK IN THE IN THE TYPICAL
SETTING THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM
WHEN -- YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT
EIGHTY IS HIM NOW RURAL AREAS
THERE ARE TYPICALLY GOING TO BE --
BECAUSE THERE'S MORE SPACE ON
LOTS ARE TYPICALLY GOING TO BE
SEPARATED BUT AND IN OUR THE
DENSER URBAN COMMUNITIES --
BUILDINGS ARE ALREADY PACKED IN
PRETTY CLOSE TO ONE ANOTHER AND
I DON'T THINK THAT -- IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN WE CERTAINLY
HAVEN'T HEARD THAT FROM -- ANY
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCY -- IF IT
WERE TO BE IDENTIFIED AS A
PROBLEM I THINK THERE ARE
PROBABLY LIMITED FIXES THAT TO
COULD BE BUILT INTO THE TO THE
BELL TO APPLY IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES YEAH HI FIRING IS
FOR CAPITAL CONCEIVABLY THAT
LOCAL AGENCY EVEN THOUGH IT'S A
LIMITATION ON THEIR POWER.
IF THE NEW DATA CAME OUT AND
INFORMATION ON ON THE FIRE
DANGER THAN THAT WOULD BE
CORRECT YOUR CRITERIA THAT THEY
COULD.
THEY COULD INCLUDE IN THEIR
EVALUATION THAT'S CORRECT OKAY
THANK YOU.
CASEY NO ADDITIONAL -- QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS -- CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU OKAY -- WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS IS ON THE BILL EIGHTY ONE
BY SOME REMEMBER BLOOM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORRELL AYE MORRELL
AYE BATES.
CARILLO.
CAROL I DRAWS -- MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE A FIVE ROUGH.
ROUGH I SKINNER.
UMBERG CASKEY.
CASSIE I AT SIX ZERO WILL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL AND NOW WE ARE
GOING -- TO TEMPORARILY LEAVE --
YOU DO YOU COLUSA AND FOR
DIFFERENT EIGHTY VOTES TODAY --
AND WE WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE THANK YOU --
THAT MISTER CHAIR -- ALSO
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- AND THAT IS
THE ELLIS ACT -- THIS IS REFORM
BILL AND TO THE BILL MAKES
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE ELSE
ACT THAT ARE INTENDED TO BOTH
ENSURE FAIRNESS FOR TENANTS AND
REMOVE AMBIGUITY FOR BOTH.
LANDLORDS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE ELLIS ACT WAS INTENDED AS A
MEANS FOR LANDLORDS TO EXIT THE
RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS.
BUT NOT INTENDED AS AN END RUN
AROUND LOCAL PROTECTIONS FOR
TENANTS AND UNFORTUNATELY -- A
LIMITED NUMBER BUT SOME
LANDLORDS USED TO LOG TO DO JUST
THAT AND THAT'S LEAD TO
UNNECESSARY LITIGATION.
AND IN MANY CASES DISPLACEMENT
OF TENANTS. TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND ABUSES A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE WILL CLARIFY THE
ELLIS ACT IN THE FOLLOWING WAYS.
FIRST IT CLARIFIES THAT WHEN A
LANDLORD WITHDRAWS A BUILDING
UNDER THE ELSE ACT THERE'S ONLY
ONE WITHDRAWAL DATE.
AND ONE DAY FOR RETURNING THE
UNITS TO THE RENTAL MARKET.
A LANDLORD WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
PICK AND CHOOSE WHICH UNITS TO
RETURN -- SECOND THE BILL
PROVIDES AN EXCEPTION TO THE TO
WHAT I JUST DESCRIBED FOR UNITS
THAT ARE OWNER OCCUPIED.
AT THE TIME OF WITHDRAWAL AND
MAKES CLEAR THAT THE PAYMENT OF
A PENALTY DOES NOT EXTINGUISH
THE LANDLORDS OBLIGATION TO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW.
AND FINALLY THE LAW CLARIFIES
THAT IF A LANDLORD ALLOWS A
TENANT WHO NEEDS MORE TIME. TO
MOVE TO STAY BEYOND THE END OF
THE TERMINATION NOTICE THAT
VOLUNTARY ACTION BY THE LANDLORD
DOES NOT EXTEND THE TIME LINE
UNDER THE ACT.
UPON TAKING THESE LAST -- AT THE
THE LAST SET OF AMENDMENTS ON
THE BILL WE RAN INTO SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES IN A LANGUAGE
WHICH SOMETIMES HAPPENS AND
WE'RE WORKING OUT THOSE
DIFFERENCES WITH CALIFORNIA
REALTORS ASSOCIATION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND WE'LL HAVE THAT
FINALIZED BY THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL PROVIDES CERTAINTY FOR
LANDLORDS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
TENANTS AND PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL SECURITY FOR THOSE
WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE FOR A TO
DISPLACEMENT IN HERE TO FURTHER
DISCUSS THE POST BRYAN ACOSTA
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS BRIAN A
GUEST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
SANTA MONICA CONTROL BOARD.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE -- I
THINK IT IS REMARKABLE THAT
AUTHORS AND A GREAT JOB OF
EXPLAINING WHAT THE BILL DOES --
BUT I THINK IT'S REMARKABLE THAT
WE HAVE AN ALICE ACT BILL THAT --
IT IN WHICH EVERYONE.
THE TENANT ADVOCATES AND THE THE
LANDLORDS ARE IN AGREEMENT ABOUT
THE CONCEPTS WERE WORKING OUT
JUST A FEW.
CHANGES TO THE LANGUAGE BARRIER
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL WE WILL
BOTH ENHANCE THE CLARITY --
PRESERVE THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF
THE LAW AND REDUCE LITIGATION
OVER SOME AMBIGUITIES EXISTED IN
THE LAW.
SO WE THINK -- THIS COMPROMISE
MEASURES VERY IMPORTANT ALL THE
MINOR CHANGE THE LAW AND WE
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON A LAWLER WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HOLY MEASURE
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD IN SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA'S ALICIA
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION --
TWEENER.
TWEETER MISTER CHAIRMAN RUN
KINGSTON REPRESENTING THREE
REGIONAL APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS
SERVE APARTMENT SO SHE XIN
ORANGE COUNTY EAST BAY RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION.
AND THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CITIES WERE
PLEASED TO HAVE WORKED WITH THE
AUTHOR OVER THE LAST.
MONTH OR SO THE JUNE TENTH
AMENDMENTS REFLECT OUR A
REQUESTED AMENDMENTS AND WE HAVE
DROPPED HER OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL -- OPPOSITION OR IN
BETWEEN PEOPLE.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CREAM THREE CM HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
AS PREVIOUSLY NOTED BY THE
AUTHOR WE DO HAVE SOME TECHNICAL
CONCERNS WITH THE JUNE TENTH
AMENDMENTS BUT WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND WITH THE
SPONSORS TO RESOLVE THOSE AND WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO RESOLVE THIS
CONCERN SHORTLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TWENTY TWO WITH THE A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SO SHE XIN
WE HAD BEEN NEUTRAL ON THE BILL
WE RECEIVED THE THE NEW LANGUAGE
LAST NIGHT -- WE WERE A BIT
SURPRISED BY THEM BUT WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
AUTHOR.
AND FEEL THAT WE CAN GET THERE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OTHER ON THIS ISSUE IN THE BILL.
RIGHT ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION OR
IN BETWEEN.
OKAY WILL BRING BACK -- TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS BILL COLLEAGUES.
OKAY -- DO PROMOTION.
BY SENATOR CABALLERO.
AND SOMEONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AT THAT THANK YOU -- AS
YOU AS YOU HEARD FROM EVERYONE --
I THINK WE ALL ANTICIPATE THAT
THE FINAL TECHNICAL -- HURDLES --
WILL BE SURMOUNTED IN SHORT
ORDER AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
OKAY WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ONLY A BILL THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE BY SOMEONE NUMBER
BLOOM THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SENATOR WIENER. FIVE ZERO BATES
[inaudible] ZERO THERE ALSO
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
ROUGH.
ROUGH I SKINNER.
AMBERG -- CASKEY.
YES.
CAROLINE.
ROTH I RESERVE. TO THE VOTERS --
THREE ZERO WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL FOR UP TO MEMBERS.
AND YOU HAVE -- SOME NUMBER ONE
FINAL BILL THAT IS NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB. SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE
THANK YOU THIS IS -- AS YOU SAID
A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE MISTER
CHAIR AND IT WILL ALLOW FOR THE
CREATION OF NONPROFIT TO A
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATIONS. TO
ISSUE BONDS THAT OUR STATE
INCOME TAX EXEMPT TO CREATE A
PREDICTABLE AND STABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDS FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES TO CREATE THE
STATE'S FIRST LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE CORPORATION WHICH WILL
ISSUE STATE INCOME TAX EXEMPT
BONDS.
AT BELOW MARKET RATE.
THE LOW COST BONDS WILL BE USED
TO FINANCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS AND ALLOW THE AGENCY TO
OFFER LOW COST MORTGAGES AND LOW
AND MIDDLE INCOME -- FOR LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOME.
HOME BUYERS LOS ANGELES IS NEW
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY WILL USE
AN INITIAL TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO FUND A PROJECTED ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
THE SELF SUSTAINING MODEL DOES
NOT REQUIRE INVESTMENTS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OR ANY TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND INSULATES THE CITY
FROM FINANCIAL RISK.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT MY OFFICE IS
WORKING WITH STAFF IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE ON AMENDMENTS WHICH
WILL INCREASE TRANSPARENCY -- AS
IS NOTED IN THE COMMUNITY AT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS -- AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE PROVIDES AN
INNOVATIVE TOOL FOR CITIES TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND WITH ME ARE.
BEEN WINTER THE CHIEF HOUSING
OFFICER OF FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND SHAUN SPEAR THE
ASSISTANT MANAGER AND A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT BUREAU THERE -- BOTH
ARE IN THEIR CAR CITIES OFFICES
I MENTION AND THEY CAN DISCUSS
THE BILL FURTHER ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
BUT GOOD AFTERNOON -- BEEN
WINTER TWO THOUSAND OFFICER FOR
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
I'M HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW CITIES
PLANNING TO CREATE A NON PROFIT
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATION. TO
SELL CONDUIT MORTGAGE REVENUE
BONDS THAT ARE EXEMPT FROM TAX --
FROM STATE INCOME TAX TO FUND
MUCH NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
AS THE HOMELESS POINT IN TIME
COUNT START TO ROLL IN ACROSS
THE STATE.
IT'S BECOME ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
THAT ARE STATEWIDE AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS AND HOUSING SHORTAGE.
ARE CLEARLY LINKED TO THE RISE
IN HOMELESSNESS.
THANKS TO VOTERS IN LOS ANGELES
WE HAVE MORE THAN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS AUTHORIZED THROUGH TO
LOCAL MEASURES PROPOSITION HHH A
MEASURE H.. TO TACKLE THIS
CHALLENGE OVER THE NEXT DECADE --
AND WE'RE ALREADY STARTING TO
SEE SOME PROGRESS FROM THESE
MEASURES.
IN COORDINATION WITH THE COUNTY
WE PERMANENTLY HOUSE MORE THAN
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND PERSONS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S MORE THAN
DOUBLE THAN WHAT WE HAD FOUR
YEARS AGO.
BUT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
FELL INTO HOMELESSNESS LAST YEAR.
OUTPACED HOW MANY PEOPLE THE
SYSTEM COULD PLACE AND A HOUSING
WHICH MEANS WE NEED AN EVEN MORE
AGGRESSIVE.
AGENDA ON THAT NOT ONLY REMOVES
REGULATORY BARRIERS FOR HOUSING
PRODUCTION OVERALL BUT ALSO LAYS
THE GROUNDWORK FOR FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGING HOW WE FINANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN LOS
ANGELES.
SO THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT GIVE CITIES LIKE LA A
NEW TOOL THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
ACCESS TO CAPITAL MARKETS LIKE
WE'VE NEVER DONE BEFORE.
LEVERAGING MORE THAN TEN DOLLARS
FOR EVERY LOCAL DOLLAR THAT WE
PUT INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
IT ALSO WILL GIVE US MUCH MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO CREATE A NEW LOAN
PRODUCTS -- TO INCREASE THE
PIPELINE OF AFFORDABLE IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND TO
ENCOURAGE MORE MIXED INCOME
DEVELOPMENTS SO FOR THOSE
REASONS MAYOR CITY IS A PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB.
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE AND THANKS
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BLOOM A FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THE MATTER.
AND WE'RE JOINED HERE A SHAUN
SPARE ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER
TO HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF
YOU MAY HAVE THEM.
THANK YOU -- ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN HOLDEN MEASURE
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HI.
IN ADDITIONAL SUPPORT I SING ON
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SAME NUMBER BACK -- TO THE
COMMITTEE -- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
YOUR CINNAMON BLOOM THEIR
MICROPHONES ON OFF IT'S TIME TO
GET A RED LIGHT ON GET THE
SERGEANT -- MAYBE I COULD ASK
BUT PERHAPS YOU DON'T SPEAK WITH
A LOUD ENOUGH VOICE.
I HARPER HARDLY THINK THAT'S THE
CASE THOUGH SENATOR.
PRETTY QUIET GUY.
IF I HEARD THIS RIGHT THE CITY'S
NOT LIABLE.
AND THERE'S NO GENERAL FUND
INVOLVEMENT.
THAT'S MY MICROPHONE MIGHT BE
BROKEN ADAM.
THAT'S CORRECT THE OF THE
NONPROFIT A PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION BE SPECIFICALLY SET
UP TO INSULATE BOTH THE CITY IN
TERMS OF ANY REVENUE OR LEGAL
RISK ASSOCIATED WITH THE
ACTIVITIES OF THE NONPROFIT --
AS WELL AS THE NONPROFIT ITSELF
IN TERMS OF LIABILITY IN TERMS
OF POSSIBLY HAVING -- FUNDS
DIVERTED FROM THE PURPOSES OTHER
THAN FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND THEN DO YOU -- HAVE DEFAULT
DEFAULT REMEDIES LIKE -- ARE YOU
GOING TO ENSURE THE BONDS -- THE
THOUGHT SO THERE ARE A COUPLE
DIFFERENT -- FINANCING
MECHANISMS THAT MIGHT BRING --
BOND AS EFFECTIVELY -- A CREDIT
ENHANCEMENT TO THE BONDS OR
EFFECTIVELY IN INSURANCE VEHICLE --
THOSE WILL BE EXPLORED AS THE
CORPORATION WOULD BE DEVELOPED.
SO THEN THE BOND HOLDERS WHICH
IS RELY ON THE NONPROFIT AND IF.
THERE'S DEFAULT AND THAT'S JUST
THE WAY GOES THAT'S YOUR RISK.
YES THAT'S THAT IS CORRECT IT
WOULD INSULATE THE CITY FROM ANY
LIABILITY ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER ANNA CABALLERO.
SO FIRST -- LET ME SAY THAT I
RIGHT THIS IS -- AN INNOVATIVE
CONCEPT I LIKE IT -- SEC A GREAT
IDEA BUT I HAVE TO SAY IT'S THE
SKINNY AS BILL [inaudible]
WITH.
I MEAN IT'S TWO PAGES RIGHT --
IT DOESN'T TELL US MUCH IN SO I
WAS STRUGGLING WITH THEM WITH
SOME OF THE DETAILS IN
PARTICULAR -- SINCE I THINK THIS
IS GOING TO BE THE MODEL FOR
OTHER CITIES THAT CAN FIND
THEMSELVES IN THE SAME UP WITH
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY A BIG CITY
WITH.
A LOT OF RESOURCES IS -- YEAH I
WAS CONCERNED THAT IN AB ONE OF
THE ISSUES I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
IS -- IF IT'S A CITY SPONSORED
IN THE IT LA IS IN THE NAME --
AT THE CREDIT -- CONFUSION THAT
MAY OCCUR YOU'RE YOU'RE DEALING
WITH BOND HOLDERS SO YOU'RE
GOING TO BE OUT IN THE MARKET --
AND THE OLD REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES HADN'T THE NAME OF THE
CITIES AS WELL AND AND AS YOU
KNOW THE CITY.
THE CITY STOOD BEHIND THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY OBLIGATIONS
AND REQUIREMENTS AND SO -- AT I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THAT I ACT
CONCERNED AS WELL AS IN TERMS OF
HOW THE BONDS GET REPAID AND I
GUESS IT'S OUT OF THE MORTGAGE.
THE THE MORTGAGE LENDING THAT'S
OCCURRED -- ALSO ABOUT BOND
LIMITS -- CAN IT BE.
YOU KNOW HOW HOW MUCH BINDING IS
APPROPRIATE.%
AND AND THEN ALL I'M IN ADDITION
CONCERNS ABOUT NEPOTISM.
AND I'M ASSUMING THAT SOME OF
THIS HOUSING WILL BE MULTI STORY
BECAUSE IT'S PRETTY HARD TO
BUILD IN A BUILT UP CITY UNLESS
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING TO DO THAT
WHICH THEN MEANS YOU'RE DOING
MAKES USE.
AND IF YOU'RE DOING MAKES USE --
THEN -- THE THE CONCERN I HAD
WAS THIS ONLY PERTAINS TO
HOUSING IT DOESN'T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR OR
PRIVATE INVESTMENT SO AT SOME
POINT YOU MAY HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING WITH PRIVATE INVESTORS --
AND THEN -- AT THAT THE FINAL
NOTE THAT I HAD IT AND I WAS
JUST TRYING.
TO THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX BECAUSE
LIKE I SAID THERE WASN'T MUCH IN
THE BILL -- THERE WEREN'T ANY
GUIDE RAILS I GUESS PUT IT THAT
WAY -- THAT THAT SAY HERE'S
HERE'S OUR MISSION HERE'S OUR
GOAL HERE'S WHAT WE WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO DRIVE TOWARDS.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT.
THAT CITIES TO BIG CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE SEEN OF A
SIGNIFICANT INFLUX OF DOLLARS
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
I THINK WE WANT TO BE CAREFUL
THAT -- THERE THERE ISN'T AND
AND THE NEPOTISM HAD TO DO WITH.
WITH -- THE THAT THAT MORTGAGE
THE MORTGAGEE MORTGAGE HOLDERS
ARE THE THE PERSON THAT PERSON'S
IT WOULD GET MORTGAGE --
MORTGAGES -- BEING FAMILY
MEMBERS OR POLITICAL FRIENDS.
AND AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
QUITE FRANKLY THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT GETS BUILT ALONG
THE COAST IN THE VERY EXPENSIVE
AREAS.
TENDS TO GO TO THE CHILDREN WHO
GREW UP THERE IN THAT COMMUNITY
WHO CUT WHO COME BACK GO GET AN
EDUCATION COME BACK.
AND THEY'RE EARNING THEIR FIRST
WAGES AND DON'T MAKE MUCH MONEY
AND THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
QUALIFIED AS OPPOSED TO THE BLUE
COLLAR WORKING CLASS -- MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY THAT HAVE BEEN
THERE FOR YEARS AND SO.
I'M INTERESTED IN THIS REALLY.
DRILLING DOWN INTO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HELP KEEP THE
ECONOMY MOVING NOT THE SONS AND
CHILDREN OF THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
THE THE REASON I WOULD I WAS
LOOKING AT THIS IN TERMS OF OF
YOU KNOW THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SOME REAL
MAJOR INVESTMENTS.
AND TO BRING AFFORDABLE REAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT BUT I
THINK THERE'S GOING TO NEED TO
BE SOME -- SOME COMMITMENT TO
SET SOME OF THIS IS THAT I DON'T
SEE IN THE BILL SO I AM GONNA
SUPPORTED TODAY BUT I JUST WANT
TO THROW THAT OUT THERE --
BECAUSE I DO THINK IT'LL BE I
THINK IT CAN BE A MODEL FOR
OTHER COMMUNITIES BUT I ALSO
DON'T WANT TO SEE A SCANDAL
HAPPENED THAT REALLY MAKES AN
EMBARRASSING SO.
I GUESS IT'S NOT A QUESTION BUT
I IF YOU'VE GOT SOME IDEAS IN
TERMS OF HOW.
IT AND MAYBE THE ENABLING
DOCUMENTS OF THAT OF THE OF THE
NONPROFIT DEAL WITH SOME OF THIS
KIND OF OF CONCERN BUT IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT IN THE BALLOT SITE.
THE COULD BE HELPFUL IF --
MISTER SPEAKER MISTER WINTER --
YEAH I I THINK TO SOME RESPONSE
SURE THANK YOU -- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND AND CONCERNS
THERE I THINK THEY ARE VALID
ONES TO HAVE WHEN DEALING WITH
INNOCENCE WHAT IS THE PUBLIC
RUST IN TERMS OF AN ENTITY THAT
WOULD BE -- SUPPORTING THE
COMMUNITIES GOALS AROUND OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND MAKING
SURE THOSE ARE GOVERNED IN A
VERY -- PROPER WAY IN A VERY
OPEN PUBLIC WAY SO WHAT I WOULD
SAY IN GENERAL IS THAT -- WHILE
THIS WOULD BE A NEW ENTITY TO
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE SIMILAR
ENTITIES -- SCATTERED THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY -- NEW YORK CITY AS
AS SORT OF SEEN AS THE BLUE
RIBBON MODEL OF THIS WITH THAT
THERE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION.
THEY REGULARLY ARE DOING MORE
THAN ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR -- IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ACTIVITY.
AND AS PART OF THAT THEY ARE SET
UP AS THOUGH IT THOUGH IT IS
TECHNICALLY SEPARATE ENTITY FROM
THE CITY -- IT HAS -- GOVERNANCE
RULES AROUND IT ACTING AS A
CONDUIT ISSUER AS WELL AS A
MORTGAGE REVENUE BOND ISSUER SO-THERE'S OPEN POLICIES IN TERMS
OF ITS ANNUAL REPORT IN TERMS OF
ITS ANNUAL AUDITS -- AS WELL AS
ITS -- PUBLIC MEETING SO THROUGH
AFFORDS BOARD OF DIRECTORS WE
WOULD BE EMULATING MANY OF THOSE
THINGS EXACTLY TO TO THE LETTER --
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS ENTITY
BECAUSE IT WILL BE A PUBLIC
BENEFIT CORPORATION SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY WHAT WE SO
WHILE HAS NOT BEEN FORMED YET
WHAT WE ARE FULLY EXPECTING?
THE CITY COUNCIL AND MAYOR WOULD
WANT TO SEE IN THIS IS THAT IT
WOULD HAVE A VERY OPEN AND
PUBLIC A GOVERNANCE.
VEHICLE MAKE SURE THAT IT
COMPLIES WITH ALL APPLICABLE
HOUSING OF A PARTICULAR FAIR
HOUSING RULES AS WELL.
SO I THINK MANY OF THOSE ISSUES
WOULD BE ADDRESSED AS PART OF
THE ORDINANCE THAT WOULD
EVENTUALLY CREATE THE THE
CORPORATION ITSELF.
THOUGH JUST TO JUST TO FOLLOW UP
ON THAT YEAR CONCEPT IS JUST
GIVE US THE AUTHORITY AND THEN
WILL TAKE THE REST OF IT AND
WE'LL PUT IT IN AN ORDINANCE.
AT THE AT THE CITY LEVEL YES THE
KEY THING IS THAT -- CITIES
ACTUALLY DO CURRENTLY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CREATE NONPROFIT
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATIONS AND
SO THERE'S ONE FOR THE AIRPORTS
AS AN EXAMPLE IN THE CITY OF LA --
THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST ONE
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON HOUSING
THOUGH SO WHAT THE BILL ACTUALLY
PROPOSES IS TO HAVE THE THE
BONDS THAT WOULD BE ISSUED BY
THE CENTER T. THAT THE CITY CAN
ALREADY CREATE.
BUT HAVE THEM BE EXEMPT FROM
STATE TAX.
OKAY THANK YOU I YEAH I'M JUST
BECAUSE WE HAVE -- THE COMMITTEE
HAS BEEN COORDINATING WITH THE
GOVERNMENT FINANCES CURRENTS OF
FINANCE COMMITTEE AND WE
UNDERSTAND I THINK THE AUTHORS
INDICATED THE BILL NEEDS TO BE
FLUSHED OUT MORE IN.
A COMMON FINANCE WILL BE DOING
THAT WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
CASEY NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SO AND WE DO HAVE A
MOTION.
SIR WAS UP FROM CENTER CABALLERO
EARLIER.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS.
COMPELLED OKAY MOVE BY CENTER
CABALLERO WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU -- AS SENATOR
CABALLERO JUST MENTIONED -- THIS
IS AN INNOVATIVE IDEA ALL THOUGH
IT'S NOT A NEW IDEA IT'S AND USE
AND OTHER SETTINGS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND SPECIFICALLY FOR
HOUSING IN.
THE CITY OF NEW YORK -- WE HAVE
THE POTENTIAL HERE TO CREATE A
LOT MORE NEW HOUSING USING THIS
NEW TOOL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU THIS PROCEDURE AND I
RECOMMENDATION ON WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ON THE BILL SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE BY SAMBAR BLOOM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS REFER THE
COMMITTEE AND GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE BATES.
BATES I CAMARO.
CAMARO HI DRAWS A MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK.
BARLACH AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
NUMBER.
UNDER AYE CASKEY.
THE BILL TO SEVEN ZERO WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL I THANK YOU SOME
MORE -- HE OKAY WHAT WE WILL
CALL THE CONSENT CALENDAR NOW.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ITEM FIVE
WHICH IS AB THREE FORTY NINE
ITEM SIX WHICH IS AB.
THREE NINETY THREE AND ITEM
ELEVEN WHICH IS AB TWELVE NINETY
THE MOTION BY SENATOR MORE
LOCKED AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE KISSING COUNTER WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS FIVE SIX
AND ELEVEN SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORRELL.
BROWN I BATES.
BATES I CAMARO.
CAMARO HI DORADO.
MCGUIRE MARLON.
MARLON I ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
UMBERG.
UNDER AYE CASKEY.
COULD SEVEN ZERO WE WILL PUT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS -- BEEN FILED
ORDER WILL CALL US A MEMBER CHIU.
FOR ITEM NUMBER
.
FOUR YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SEND SENATORS AB
THREE THIRTY EIGHT UPDATED
EXISTING SMOKE DETECTOR.
STANDARD BY REQUIRING A LIST AT
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S SMOKE
DETECTOR TO BE PRIESTS THE
PRESIDENT OF HONG LEASING OR
CELLS OFFER MOBILE PHONE OR
MANUFACTURING HOME.
IT WILL ALSO IMPROVE.
TO **** TO THE MOBILE HOME PARK
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLAN TO
REQUIRED AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. TO TRANSLATE THE
EXISTING PLAN IN TWO LANGUAGES
THAT ARE SPOKEN BY 5% OF THE
POPULATION SERVED.
UNDER THIS BILL PART OWNER WILL --
MAKE SURE THAT THE TRANSLATE A
PLAN OF AVAILABLE WITH THE
ENGLISH VERSION AND NOTIFY AT AT
THE AT THE ODD I THINK I THE
CLUB HOUSE.
AND ALSO NOTIFIED RESIDENTS ONCE
A YEAR THAT THOSE MATERIALS ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THIS CONVERSATION -- DID DID THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS BILL
BECAME AT THE CHARGES FIRE IN MY
DISTRICT IN CELLS A MOVE MOBILE
HOME FIRE.
KILLED THREE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND TO ALL OF THEM WERE A YOUNG
CHILDREN AND BECAUSE OF THE
STRUCTURE OF THE MOBILE HOME.
AND THE DID TO THE TIGHT SPACE
IN THE MOBILE HOME PARK -- MAKE
SHOULD MAKE THE MOBILE PHONE
FIRES -- VERY EASY TO THE SPREAD.
OF AND AND AND CALLS.
MORE OF A DISASTERS SO THIS BILL
WAS SAFE LIFE AND ALSO A HELP
PEOPLE TO PREPARE.
OF WANTED DECISIVE REDUCED TO
DISASTER HITS.
AND AB THREE THIRTY EIGHT IS
SPONSORED BY THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE.
AND IN YOUR SUPPORT FROM THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND GOLDEN STATE
MANUFACTURER HOMEOWNERS.
AND OTHERS WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT I HAVE AND THE
ELDORADO ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE.
AND ROGER JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
THE GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURING
HOME OWNERS LEAGUE.
HELLO.
EVERYONE START MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND I'LL FRAUD CASES --
WITH EVERY THREE WITNESSES
TESTIFYING.
LOW RESERVE STUFF CAM HI BENEFIT
OUR IF YOU COULD LIMITED TO
THREE MINUTES EACH PLEASE THANK
YOU EARLY.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS AND ALL
BROUGHT A WITH CRUISE STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE AND WE'RE HERE AS PROUD
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE.
AND AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED SAN JOSE DID
EXPERIENCE A DEVASTATING FIRE A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT TOOK THE
LIVES OF TWO CHILDREN.
AND ONE ADULT LIVING IN A MOBILE
HOME COMMUNITY THE FIRE STRUCK
IN ONE OF THE THREE MOBILE HOME
PARKS IN SAN JOSE THE ONLY
MONTHS EARLIER HAD FLOODED WITH
COYOTE CREEK TOPPED.
ITS BANKS DURING THESE LAST TWO
YEARS THE SOUND OF THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT HAS RESPONDED TO
TWENTY SIX MOBILE HOME FIRES IN
OUR JURISDICTION.
THIS BILL REALLY IS ABOUT
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND WHILE
FIRST REPORT RESPONDERS KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT TO DO AT THE TIME
OF A DISASTER WE NEED TO ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT RESIDENTS ARE
INFORMED.
OF EVACUATION READ ANY READINESS
AND PREPARED FOR THE NEXT FIRE
FLOOD OR EARTHQUAKE FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
DRIVE OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ROGER JOHNSON.
I'M A SENIOR -- VETERAN.
AND A MOBILE HOMEOWNER.
IN LAKE VIEW VILLAGE IN CITRUS
HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE GOLDEN
STATE MOBILE HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE
GSM WHILE.
REPRESENTING SENIORS VETERANS.
IMMIGRANTS ANOTHER LOW MODERATE
AND FIXED INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES.
WHO LIVE IN MOBILE HOME PARKS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE?
GSM WELL SUPPORTS A. B..
THREE THREE EIGHT REQUIRING
PROPER SMOKE ALARMS.
AN EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLANTS.
WE WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU FOR RE INTRODUCING THIS
BILL.
SINCE THIS BILL WAS VETOED LAST
YEAR.
THE STATE HAS X. SPERRY INST
MORE DEVASTATION FROM FIRES.
INCLUDING.
THE CAMP FIRE [inaudible]
IN PARADISE.
WHERE MANY LIVES [inaudible]
MOBILE HOMES.
AND MOBILE HOME PARKS WERE LOST.
YOU CANNOT BE TOO PREPARED. FOR
A FIRE WHEN IT COMES TO
CALIFORNIA FIRES.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS IMPORTANT SAFETY
ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM STONE OF
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF ALL
STATE INSURANCE IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN I'LL BE OFF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND SUPPORT.
MELISSA ORDER WITH THE AMERICAN
RED CROSS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IN ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
OKAY OPPOSITION.
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS CHAIR
THE UNDER GOVERNOR ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION WMA.
WE ARE THE LARGEST ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING THE LONG PARK
OWNERS IN THE STATE.
IF THE BILL WERE AMENDED TO JUST
BE SECTION ONE WE WOULD SUPPORT
THE MEASURE HOWEVER WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SECTION TO
IN THE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
PLANS.
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS OF THE
ONLY NON SUBSIDIZED HOUSING IN
THE STATE THAT HAS TO ALREADY
PREPARE AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PLAN.
BUT WE THINK THAT SECTION TWO
WAS REFUNDED FOR TWO REASONS
NUMBER ONE THE LEGISLATURE JUST
ALLOCATED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. TO GO
TOWARDS LOCAL COMMUNITIES INTO
EDUCATION PROGRAMS FOR DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS.
THEY ALSO ALLOCATED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO UPGRADE THE NETWORK
FOR EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
AND THEN FINALLY.
AT THE AMERICAN RED CROSS DOT
COM FEMA DOT GOV CALLAWAY YES
GOT GOV AND READY DOT GOV THE RT
TRANSLATE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
AT CISCO US IN THIS BILL IN
ALMOST THIRTY LANGUAGES. TO OUR
POINT IS WHY DO THIS N THE BILL
WHY WHEN YOU JUST SMPLY HAVE
EIGHT CD POST ON THEIR WEBSITE
ACCESS TO THE WEBSITE.
OPERATORS ALREADY UPON TENANTS
THE ALREADY AFTER VIDE
NOTIFICATION OF WHERE TO LOOK SO
WHY WOULD YOU SIMPLY SPEND EXTRA
MONEY TO DO SOMETHING THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS ALREADY DONE.
AND ACTUALLY EVEN NONPROFIT
ENTITIES HAVE DONE SO FOR THESE
REASONS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
CASING THAT WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
YES SENATOR MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MEASURE I I WAS
THINKING THE SAME THING I WAS
THINKING.
WHY DON'T WE MAKE IT A LITTLE
SIMPLER JUST AND?
THE APPLICABLE LANGUAGES SAY
PLEASE GO TO W. W. W. DOT.
AND THEN USUAL GOOGLE APP TO
TRANSLATE TO YOU CAN READ THE
EMERGENCY PLAN -- WOMEN JUST
SEEM TO MAKE IT IN YET SO
OVERBEARING AND THAT I THINK
IT'S OUR IT'S AN EASY AMENDMENT
TO MAKE TO THE BILL.
JUST AN OBSERVATION.
THANK YOU MAY I RESPOND YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION I EAT.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THE
MOST HELPFUL THE BUT RESIDENTS
IN THE MOBILE HOME PARK.
WHEN I EVEN HAVE A COMPUTER
ACCESS?
SO YOU KNOW YOU YOU COULD HAVE
ON THE WEBSITE SOMEWHERE.
BUT I AT THIS BILL WILL MANDATE
THAT THE MOBILE HOME.
OWNER TO HAVE SOMETHING IN PRINT
IN THE CLUBHOUSE AND THEN NOTIFY
THE RESIDENT. TO TERROR THERE IS
A DOCUMENT THERE IN A REVIEW IT
AND REBUILD IT TO IN THE
LANGUAGE OF FEWER.
ORIGIN.
SO IT IS VERY DIFFERENT YOU KNOW
USE USE OF WHILE I HAVE
SOMETHING ON THE WEBSITE.
AND AND VERSUS A HAND THE DIAL.
HANDED DOWN A PRINTED COPY AND
AND AND ASK THEM TO READ IT.
THIS.
THUS OF DIFFERENCES BUT THAT CAN
BE DONE BY GOING TO THE PROPERTY
MANAGERS OFFICE SAYING I'D LIKE
TO HAVE A COPY AND FILL IN THE
LANGUAGE A LOT WE XIN.
AND THEY COULD THEY COULD THEN
GO TO FINALLY GOT A PRINTER AND
A AND A COMPUTER HERE WE CAN.
DOWNLOAD IT AND JUST PUT IT FOR
YOU.
AS OPPOSED TO HAVING JUST ALL
THESE COPIES OF OF PAPER I RIGHT
NOW I THINK THE LOG OF AMENDED
THEY HAVE A COPY IN ENGLISH. FOR
THE SECOND PART WAS REALLY JUST
A TRANSLATION PART WANTED TO BE
IN SPANISH BECAUSE THAT'S WHO
THE OVER THE STRESSFUL OF 5%.
OF THE POPULATION THAT WE SERVE
IN CALIFORNIA STOLE THIS BILL
WILL ONLY ADD A TRACTOR
TRANSLATED VERSION NEXT TO THE
ENGLISH VERSION.
SO FOES FORWARD -- TO LINK
ENGLISH LEARNER AB OVAL TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT -- WELL MAYBE
I COULD JUST AS THE OPPOSITION
QUESTION YOU KNOW I'M.
SOMEWHAT SENSITIVE TO THIS
BECAUSE MY FATHER IN LAW LIVES
IN ONE OF THESE PARKS AND MY
FATHER IN LAW'S. EIGHTY OR
EIGHTY ONE YEARS OLD ENOUGH.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
SINCE THE NOTICE REQUIRES OF
PLAN BE POSTED IN ENGLISH HE'S
AN ENGLISH SPEAKER BUT I CAN
ASSURE YOU THE NOT ONLY.
DOES NOT HAVE A OWN A COMPUTER
DOES NOT HAVE ONE IS MOBILE HOME
I DON'T THINK HE WOULD KNOW
FRANKLY WITH WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO THE TURN IT ON IF I
PROVIDED HIM ON SO I'M JUST
WONDERING.
WHAT THE REAL IMPACT IS TO THE?
PARK OWNERS TO COMPLY WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS. FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- TO POST A
NOTICE IN SPANISH GIVEN THE
NUMBER OF SPANISH SPEAKERS THAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE I'M TRYING
TO BE SENSITIVE TO REQUIREMENTS
ON BUSINESS AND AND I HAVING
BEEN A BUSINESS OPERATOR MYSELF
AND HAVING HAD THE ENTIRE BACK
WALL OF MY OFFICE FILLED WITH
POSTERS -- REQUIRED.
I GUESS BY US.
I'M SOMEWHAT SENSITIVE TO THIS.
BUT MAYBE YOU COULD WITH WITH
TERMS PERMISSION.
WELL FIRST OFF IT'S NOT ABOUT US
TRANSLATING RIGHT NOW CAL -- YES
HAS DEVELOPED A MODEL PLAN NOT
EIGHT CD WHICH IS WHO WOULD BE
DOING THE TRANSLATION CALLOW YES
IS DONE. EIGHT CD WE WOULD WE
GET A GET A REQUEST IN THEORY
AND THEN PASS ALONG DATE CITY
FOR TRANSLATION ATV IS THE ONE
THAT HAS TO DO THE TRANSLATION.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T BE LIABLE FOR
THE TRANSLATION.
IF THERE'S ANY DELAY IN
TRANSLATION WRESTLING THE
REQUIREMENT WE ACTUALLY GET OUR
ABILITY ARE PERMITS OPERATE IS
SUSPENDED.
WHICH IS THE PERMIT WHICH AN
OPERATOR GETS TO COLLECT RENT.
SO BY NO ACTION OF OUR OWN COULD
WE ACTUALLY BE PENALIZED BY THE
DEPARTMENT NOT FILLING THE
RESPONSIBILITY I'M BY NO MEANS
BY THE WAY DO WE FEEL THAT.
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE THE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS MATERIAL
WE ACTUALLY WORK WITH SENATOR
PER DIEM WHEN HE PASSED THE
ORIGINAL BILL ON THE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PLAN.
BUT WHAT THE BILL IS NOW BEEN
AMENDED TO WAS NOT THE FIRST
SECTION OF THE END OF THE THIS
PLAN WHICH HAS TO DO WITH
EVACUATION OF THE PARK.
SECTION TO MERELY HAS TO DO WITH
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF AN
INDIVIDUAL FOR INSTANCE HAVE YOU
NOTICED DO YOU HAVE A PLACE TO
GO IN CASE OF AN EMERGENCY.
DO YOU REMEMBER TO TAKE YOUR
MEDICINES HAVE YOU TAKEN YOUR
INSURANCE CARD EVERYTHING THAT
WHETHER YOUR LIVE IN A MOBILE
HOME PARK AN APARTMENT CONDO OR
A HOMEOWNER SHOULD ALL HAVE THAT
INFORMATION OUR POINT IS ALWAYS
BEEN WE ARE TO PROVIDE THE
BASICS IN ENGLISH WE PROVIDE.
ACCESS TO LET THEM KNOW WHERE TO
GET IT BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE THE
MOBILE HOME PARKS OPERATOR. TO
TELL EVERY RESIDENT EXACTLY THAT
THEY NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
THEIR EXTRA MEDICINE BECAUSE
REALLY THE THE RESIDENTS THE
MANAGER THE LIVES IN A PARK IS
ALSO A RESIDENT AND THEY'RE JUST
TRYING TO GET OUT AND WE WORK
WITH PADILLA ON THE BILL.
THE EMERGENCY RESPONDERS DID NOT
WANT US TO INTERVENE IN ANY OF
THIS BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
GIVE PEOPLE A FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY THAT THE MOBILE HOME
PARK MANAGER OPERATOR IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR SAFETY.
IS IN AN EMERGENCY IT TO JUST BE
THE EMERGENCY RESPONDERS SO WE
DON'T OBJECT TO HAVING MORE
INFORMATION WE JUST LEAVE THE
INFORMATIONS ALREADY OUT THERE
AND THAT THE GOVERNMENT BOTH THE
STATE AND FEDERAL OF ALREADY
DONE ALL THESE TRANSLATIONS.
IN THAT BASIC SECTION TWO AND IT
SHOULDN'T BE REDUNDANT FREIGHT
CITY TO HAPPEN NOW SPEND MORE
MONEY THAN TRANSLATE THESE EXTRA
PLANS.
THE SERVER MOMMY MAKE SURE
INSTANCE OF THE LAW.
PARTY REQUIRES AN ENGLISH
VERSION OF THE NOTICE TO BE
POSTED.
AND SO MAYBE I MISUNDERSTAND
THIS BILL THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES.
A NOTE THE NOTE THE SAME NOTICE
TO BE PUBLISHED IN ANOTHER
LANGUAGE GIVEN CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS.
AND THE THE BILL REQUIRES.
A STATE AGENCY. TO TRANSLATE THE
DOCUMENT AND I PRESUME MAKE IT
AVAILABLE TO PARK OWNERS AND
POSTED ON ITS WEBSITE.
AND POSTERS WEBSITE.
AND I GUESS THE OPPOSITION IN
YOUR COMPLAINT IS THAT.
THERE MAY BE A DELAY IN THE
TRANSITIONAL ATION IS SOME
LIABILITY BECAUSE WE COULD I
WOULD SAY I'M ASSUMING THE
AUTHOR WITH A CHEST.
THE BILL TO RELIEVE THE PARK
OWNERS FROM LIABILITY
RESPONSIBILITY IF IT'S THE
STATE'S PROBLEM AND THAT YOU
DON'T GET THE TRANSLATION IN
TIME TO POSTED ON THE BOARD.
YES THAT'S PART OF IT YEP THE
RIGHT.
YEAH I'M A FINANCE ARE NOT.
OKAY CENTER CABALLERO.
IT'S INTERESTING IT SAM IT'S A
PRETTY SIMPLE BILL BUT I MIGHT
MY ISSUE IS I WAS A LITTLE BIT
OF A TWIST ON ALL OF THIS --
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY I MEAN
I I A WAS THE SECRETARY OVER
EACH CD.
AND QUITE FRANKLY.
WE END UP GIVING THESE DUTIES TO
DEPARTMENTS THAT DON'T HAVE
[inaudible]
THE STAFF OR THIRTY OR ABILITY
TO DO TRANSLATING SERVICES SINCE
WHEN DO WE SEND INFORMATION EACH
CD TRANSLATE YOU KNOW IT IT JUST
ALL I'D.
I'D MUCH RATHER EACH CD MAKE
SURE PEOPLE ARE BUILDING HOMES
IN COMMUNITIES IN A RECALCITRANT
IN THAT ARE NOT BUILDING THE
RENO NUMBERS THEN TO BE DOING
TRANSLATION SERVICES SO I WAS
LOOKING AT THIS AND SAYING.
WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE CONCERN WAS FROM -- THE
MANUFACTURED HOUSING --
POSITIONED BUT I WAS JUST TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHY ARE WE SENDING
IT TO EACH CD WHEN WHEN IT IT.
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR MOBILE
HOME -- BUT BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THERE ARE ANY YEAR
TRANSLATION SERVICES.
AND THEY THEY MAY BE LOCATED
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND AND AND IT
JUST SEEMS ODD TO ME.
I'M NOT WILLING TO BLOW IT UP
TODAY BUT I'M I IT JUST
[inaudible]
SEEMED ODD.
MY REYES FROM THE DISS ASPIRIN
DISCUSSED AND OF WHAT WAS SAID --
H. CITY AND ALL YES AND THE
REASON THAT WE LEAVE IT WAS --
TO IT'S EIGHT EIGHT DD IS
BECAUSE HER SCHOOL THE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
AND THIS BILL -- THE FACT THIS
BILL DO FOR SOFTBALL REQUIRED.
THE FIRE MARK A MARSHALL
CERTIFIED THE SMOKE DETECTORS
ONE PART.
AND SUDDENLY TO TRANSLATION PART
AND UNCERTAIN THIRD LEAVE VERY
IMPORTANT IS FOR THE PARK OWNER
TO PROACTIVELY REACH ALL TO THE
REST OF THE LET THEM KNOW ABOUT
THIS PLAN IS NOT YOUR SOUL I
HELP THIS PLAN BARRY SOMEWHERE.
YOU KNOW IF YOU INTEREST DEBUT
COMMA ABSOLUTE IN THE OLD PORT
AT ALL YOU KNOW AND AND DOES IT
ALL AND PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
ENGLISH VERSION.
OR YOU CAN I YOU WERE READING.
SO THAT THE THIRD PART IS VERY
IMPORTANT IS FOR THE OWNER TO
PRO ACTIVELY REACHING OUT TO TO
THE RESIDENT TO SAVE OKAY WILL
WELCOME YOU TO THE PARK WELL A
LOT WARMER LE LET YOU KNOW.
ON A REGULAR BASIS SAFETY PLAN
IS HAVING A PAPER ON THE BACK
WALL DOESN'T DOESN'T GET THERE
AND I AND I HAVE TO AGREE YOU
KNOW THE KIND OF POSTING THAT
YOU DO AS AN EMPLOYER -- YOU PUT
HIM UP BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO AND
THEY'RE VERY DETAILED AND VERY
RARELY ARE THEY READ IF WE
REALLY WANT SAFETY.
THAN WHAT MAKES SENSE TO ME%
RATHER THAN POSTING NOTICES AND
DOING IT IN A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES THAT MAYBE.
ONE PASSING THEM OUT MAY BE GOOD
BUT IT IT WOULD BE A BOMB TO DO
A DRILL ONCE A YEAR WHERE --
EVERYBODY COMES TO THE CLUBHOUSE
OR WHEREVER IT IS THAT YOU CAN
MEET ON THE FACILITY AND YOU
TALK ABOUT WHETHER IT WHAT'S THE
PLAN IF THERE'S A FIRE HERE IF
IF WE HAD TO EVACUATE QUICKLY.
WHAT SHOULD PEOPLE BE DOING WHAT
WHERE SHOULD THEY BE LOOKING FOR
ASSISTANCE AND IT'S YOUR
ABSOLUTE RIGHT IT'S NOT THE PARK
MANAGER IT'S IT'S LISTENING TO
THE OFFICIALS -- AND AND THAT
THAT SEEM TO ME. TO TO BE -- IF
IF SAFETY IS OUR REAL ISSUE THEN
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
IN IN MANY OF THESE.
THESE UNITS THEIR THEIR SENIORS
THEY'RE NOT GONNA MOVE VERY FAST
THEY'RE NOT THERE'S GOING TO BE
CONFUSION -- AND YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO RIGHT AWAY SO
THAT THEY CAN GET THEMSELVES TO
A PLACE OF SAFETY AWAY FROM.
THE THE THE PERSON I WAS GOING
TO COME IN AND TRY TO PUT OUT
WHATEVER THE DISASTER IS SO THAT.
JUST MY TWO CENTS WORTH BUT WE
WOULD DO -- SEND OUT COULD COULD
STUDIO DAY THE MANAGERS AND THE
RESIDENTS ARE COMMUNICATE ON THE
WILL MONTHLY BASIS WHEN THEY
HAVE TO PAY THE RENT.
SO THIS BILL WOULD JUST SAYING
THAT ONCE THE ONCE A YEAR.
THAT THE MANAGER SHOULD OF
INFORM.
AND I LET THE RESIDENTS KNOWS
ABOUT THIS PLAN.
IS AVAILABLE FOR THEM AND THE
CLUB HOUSE INTO CAN COME AND
READ OF ALL THAT OCCURRED XIN TO
DO.
OKAY A SINGLE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS -- DO WE
HAVE A MOTION.
MOVED BY SENATOR ROTH AND TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE YOU YUBA
AGAIN THIS THIS IS THE BILLS SAY
FLY FOR I ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL
DOES ENJOY AND I RECOMMENDATION
AND WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ON THE BILL THREE THIRTY
EIGHT BY SIGN NUMBER TO MOTIONS
TO PASS AND REFER THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
I MORAL.
MORRELL NO BATES.
BATES NO CARRIER.
HI DORADO MCGUIRE.
WARLOCK [inaudible]
ROUGH [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
NUMBER.
NUMBER I BECAUSE HE THE VOTERS
FORTY TWO WILL PUT THAT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
I THINK IT'S CENTERS THANK YOU
FOR AND COLORS AS A REMINDER WE
DO AT THE END OF EACH.
MEETING WE AWARD THE HONORARY --
MIKE MCGUIRE AWARD TO A MEMBER
WHO ARRIVES LAST.
I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THERE
ARE THREE MEMBERS WHO ARE
COMPETING FOR THE HONOR -- THIS
TIME THEY ARE SENATORS TO ROSS
SO MCGUIRE AND SKINNER AND
CENTER MCGUIRE DOES OFTEN WHEN --
THE AWARD THE SAME AFTER HIMSELF.
OKAY -- WE WILL -- WE WILL NEXT --
GOOD ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FOR
THIRTY BY -- SOME MEMBER
GALLAGHER.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS --
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AB FOR THIRTY TO YOU --
AND I KNOW WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS -- SO THIS
IS THE CAMPFIRE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN HI AS YOU ALL KNOW --
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH -- A
DEVASTATING DISASTER IN IN OUR
COMMUNITY -- WHEN THE CAMP FIRE
SWEPT THROUGH AND -- WIPED OUT --
THE TOWN OF PARADISE IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF MIGUEL YET CON
CAO AND YANKEE HILL -- THE FIRE
DISPLACED OVER [inaudible]
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
I WILL TAKE MANY YEARS -- FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES TO REBUILD --
AND IN THE MEANTIME EVACUEES
NEED TO BE ABLE TO FIND STABLE
HOUSING IN THE REGION -- WHILE
SOME NOW AND I BELIEVE A VERY
STRONG CONTINGENT WILL RETURN TO
PARADISE AND AND REBUILD THAT.
TOWN EVEN MORE RESILIENT SAFER
INTO THE FUTURES MANY.
PEOPLE WILL.
MAYBE DECIDED NOT TO REBUILD AND
NEED TO THE STAND THE REGION
WHERE THEY HAVE FAMILY JOB
OPPORTUNITIES THEIR KIDS GO TO
SCHOOL.
IN THE REGION.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS -- AS AS AS
WE KNOW WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT WAS.
CERTAINLY THE CASE IN BUTTE
COUNTY BEFORE AND IT'S EVEN
WORSE NOW 14% OF BUTTE COUNTY'S
HOUSING STOCK -- WAS DESTROYED --
THE COUNTY FELL SEVENTEEN PLACES
MORE THAN ANY OTHER COUNTY IN
THE STATE ON THE AFFORDABILITY
INDEX.
OF THE RENTAL MARKET VACANCY
RATE ALSO FELL TO NEARLY.
ZERO AFTER THE FIRE -- SO THIS
IS ALL MAKING IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT. FOR CAN'T FIE
VICTIMS AND OTHERS TO FIND
HOUSING -- AND SO EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY WOULD PROVIDE A
STREAMLINED MINISTERIAL APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR BUILDING HOUSING
PROJECTS IN IN THE IN THE VALLEY.
IN THE BUTTE COUNTY REGION AND
IN THE URBAN CENTERS OF THE
REGION -- WE THE BILL DOES ONLY
APPLY -- IN THOSE URBAN REGIONS
WHERE THERE IS BEEN A GENERAL
PLAN.
DESIGNATION FOR RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT -- IT ALSO INCLUDES
PROTECTIONS PREVENTIVE ELEMENTS
FROM BEING BUILT. FOR EXAMPLE IN
FLOOD PLAINS OR ON LANDS THAT
ARE ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
INCLUDING WETLANDS -- AND WHERE
THERE IS -- HABITAT.
INVOLVING ENDANGERED SPECIES.
SO -- I BELIEVE THIS IS A A GOOD
AND USEFUL TOOL I AGAIN WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR WORKING
WITH US -- I THINK THE
OPPOSITION THE ONLY OPPOSITION
OF THAT HAS BEEN REGISTERED HAD.
WAS DEALING WITH THE CITY OF
CHICO ONE AB REMOVED WE HAVE
DONE THAT -- AND ALSO SOME TALK
ABOUT A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
INCLUSIONARY ZONING WHICH THE
AMENDMENT.
ADDRESSES OF THIS WOULD PRECLUDE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS -- FOR
MAKING THEIR OWN DECISIONS TO IN
INCLUDE INCLUSIONARY ZONING --
LOCALLY SO AGAIN I APPRECIATE
THE WORK ON THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR MY COMMUNITY AND I
WOULD ASK.
FOR YOUR AYE THE I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
FISH MISTER CHAIRMAN VERY
BRIEFLY -- PAUL YOU'RE ON BEHALF
OF THE BIãU COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL BUT ALSO JUST DON'T WANT TO
MISS ANY OPPORTUNITY THINK THIS
ENTIRE LEGISLATURE THE NEWSMEN
MINISTRATION. FOR ALL THE
MANIFESTATIONS OF SUPPORT FOR
BI<c.cyan> COUNTY FOR PARADISE.</c>
BILLS LIKE THIS AND ALSO BUT
BUDGET ITEMS WE'RE JUST VERY
GRATEFUL TRYING TO REBUILD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
BUT AFTERNOON JOHN KENNEDY WITH
THE WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
WE THINK IT'S A GOOD WAY TO
FACILITATE REBUILDING.
AND A HARD HAT AREA THANK YOU.
YES OVER THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED
TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
SILVIO PRIME HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND THE CIVIL JUSTICE CESSATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OKAY OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RICHARD
HERMAN.
ON THE GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER.
WE'VE SUBMITTED WRITTEN.
OPPOSITION.
IN IT SHOULD BE IN THE FILE --
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE BILL HAD DOES NOT REALLY DO
WHAT IT SAYS IT DOES.
THE NEW AMENDMENTS. TO FOUR
THIRTY HEAD DO LITTLE OR NOTHING
WITH RESPECT TO EXPEDITING
CONSTRUCTION.
OF HOUSING FOR DISPLACED PER DAY
SURVIVORS.
IT IS INTENDED TO EXPLOIT THE
EMOTIONAL CAMPFIRE DISASTER TO
FAST TRACK URBAN SPRAWL
DEVELOPMENT IN THE SOUTH
SACRAMENTO VALLEY.
I SPEAK FROM EXPERIENCE AS
SOMEONE WHO IS LITIGATING ON THE
PGA ANY CASES.
THAT I TALK WITH THE SURVIVORS
OF PARADISE ATTEND.
AND THE NUMBERS THAT ARE
PRESENTED TO YOU ARE MISLEADING.
BECAUSE THERE WILL ALREADY NOT
BE ANYWHERE NEAR FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT ARE NEEDED.
AS FAR AS THE NEED FOR HOUSING.
WITH RESPECT TO THE SPECIFIC
ISSUES OF THE BILL.
THE FACTS IN THE BILL ITSELF
REALLY DEMONSTRATE THAT IT
DOESN'T ADDRESS WHAT IT SAYS
IT'S GOING TO ADDRESS.
FIRST OF ALL THE DENSITY THAT IS
THE MINIMUM DENSITY.
OR IS FOUR UNITS PER ACRE.
ANOTHER PROVISION IS IT'S ONLY
TWO THIRDS OF THE AREA IS FOR
RESIDENTIAL SOME OF IT CAN BE
MIXED USE.
SO IT'S NOT REALLY FOCUSED ON
RESIDENTIAL IT'S AFFORDABLE.
AND THAT'S ANOTHER PROBLEM.
YOUR STAFF ANALYSIS BY MISUSE.
TEED UP THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
INHERENT IN THE BILL IT REALLY
DOESN'T ADDRESS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT DOESN'T
ENSURE THAT PARADISE SURVIVORS
WILL BE.
BUYERS OR RENTERS OF THE HOUSING.
AND WHAT IT REALLY DOES WITH A
FIFTY ACRE MAXIMUM THAT'S
ALLOWED.
AT THE RATE OF FOUR UNITS PER
ACRE.
IF FOR THE MINIMUM DENSITY IN
ORDER TO DO IT IT'S NOT REALLY
DENSE HOUSING.
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY HAS A THE
DWELLING UNIT PER ACRE.
AVERAGE IT SHOOTS FOR WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EFFECTIVELY FAST
TRACKING URBAN SPRAWL
DEVELOPMENT IN THE CELL
SACRAMENTO VALLEY.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS ALREADY THE
LARGE SCALE DEVELOPERS NOW
COMING UP TO THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY TO START DEVELOPING?
OUR OBJECTION IS THAT THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION IS NOT THE NECESSARY.
IT'S ALREADY EXISTENCE SEEK WHAT.
AND FURTHER MORE WHAT IT DOES IS
IT RADICALLY CHANGES THE RATE OF
GROWTH THAT WILL BE EXPERIENCED
IN THE COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE
DESIGNATED.
FINALLY TO CLOSE I DID A DRIVE
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICT.
OF THE ASSEMBLY MAN THE AUTHORS
DISTRICT.
THESE ARE SMALL TOWNS.
THEY DON'T NEED A SEQUEL
EXCEPTION TO START MOVING
FORWARD.
SHE BECAUSE BEEN WITHDRAWN SHE
BECAUSE THE ONE THAT IS A ONE IS
CAN BE DEALING WITH IT WHAT WE
REALLY NEED IS FUNDING FOR
PLANNING AND SUPPORT. FOR MORE
DENSE DEVELOPMENT IN THE CITY OF
CHICO.
BY THE WAY OUR ORGANIZATION AND
OTHERS THAT I REPRESENTED
SUPPORTED EIGHTY USE IN CHICO WE
HAVE ADOPTED THAT MEASURE IN THE
CITY CHICO SO WE BELIEVE AND
DENSITY.
OF DEVELOPMENT WE BELIEVE IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND WE
SUPPORT THAT.
THIS BILL SIMPLY DOES NOT BRING
THAT TO THE VALLEY.
IT IS ESSENTIALLY GOING TO
REPLICATE THE SAME MISTAKES THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE AND URBAN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE BAY AREA WHERE I GREW UP
AND I REALLY WANT TO SEE THAT
HAPPEN AGAIN.
THE CUMULATIVE IMPACTS IT WILL
BE IGNORED BECAUSE OF THE SEEK
TO EXEMPTION ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE GOING TO LEAD THE WAY TO
MORE SPRAWL.
THAT WILL LEAD THE WAY TO
FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES FOR THE
SMALLER COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO EXPAND
SO RAPIDLY.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE THE SAME KIND
OF TRANSPORTATION AIR QUALITY
PROBLEMS AND OTHER PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN IN THE PAST
WE DON'T NEED TO BE DRIVING A
REAR VIEW MIRROR.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT NOT
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
CRISTINA WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE -- COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
BILL [inaudible]
CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
FOR SMALL DO APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL ALONG WITH
YOUR FANTASTIC TEAM AND I ALSO
WANT.
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF FOR HIS
HARD WORK ON THIS ISSUE IN
OBVIOUSLY ALL ISSUES THE
RECOVERY -- UNDERSTAND IT
THERE'S BEEN AMENDMENTS TAKEN TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH A
SURROUNDING CITIES.
THIS.
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S CONTINUE
CONCERN [inaudible]
AND THERE'S NEVER BEEN AN
INCIDENT LIKE THIS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY NEVER. TO THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF WHAT'S HAPPENED IN
PARADISE -- AND I APPRECIATE.
YOU BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
IT'S COMMONSENSE IN REGARDS TO
THE STREAMLINING -- END WE DON'T
HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF CHOICE.
THE QUICKER THEY'RE STILL
CLEANING UP IN THAT COMMUNITY
THE QUICKER WE CAN START GETTING
SIX UP -- IN PEOPLE BACK IN
THEIR HOMES THE BETTER IS GOING
TO BE AND UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
MAY BE CAN YOU CONCERNED BUT I
APPRECIATE YOU LOOKING AT ALL
AVENUES TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HELP AS
WELL ON ON THE MANY ISSUES WHO
ARE WORKING ON ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
OKAY -- WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
CABALLERO AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- I
JUST YOU KNOW ADDRESS SOME OF
THE THINGS WERE BROUGHT UP --
YOU KNOW ONE THIS DISC CANNOT
ALLOW SPRAWL SPRAWL.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THIS CAN
ONLY BE USED IN THE CITY LIMITS
OF INCORPORATED CITIES IN BUTTE
COUNTY -- SO THE UNINCORPORATED
PARTS THE COUNTY WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO UTILIZE THIS STREAMLINED
PROCESS -- SO AND THE OTHER IN
THE OTHER ISSUE IS YOU KNOW THE
BIGGEST OPPOSITION WAS FROM THE
CITY OF CHICO THEY DID NOT WANT
TO BE PART OF THIS SO THEY'VE
BEEN REMOVED FROM THE BILL.
AS WE ADDRESS THAT CONCERN --
THIS THIS IS GONNA HELP TO ME
IT'S GOING TO HELP AFFORDABLE
INFILL.
PROJECTS MORE THAN ANYTHING --
BECAUSE OF THE PROJECTS THAT
OFTEN GET HELD UP -- BY SYKORA --
HIM BEING USE KIND OF AS A GUY'S
NAME BE ISM -- WE NEED AS MUCH
HOUSING AS POSSIBLE WE NEED ALL
AND WE NEED ALL FORMS OF IT IN
THIS IN THIS CRISIS THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW IT'S ONE
TOOL.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING ON MANY OTHER
THINGS IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
HOUSING CREDITS TO HELP SUPPORT
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
REGION -- WERE INFRASTRUCTURE
REBUILDING -- YEAH SO THIS THIS
IS ONE TOOL AMONG MANY TO HELP A
COMMUNITY.
REBUILD ITSELF AND BE MORE
SUSTAINABLE -- RESILIENT INTO
THE FUTURE SO THANK YOU FOR YOU
I WOULD JUST ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT -- WHAT I THINK IS A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH
THAT WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ON THE BILL FOR THIRTY
BY SOME MEMBER GALLAGHER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER THE COMMITTEE.
ON ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY SENATOR
WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORROW.
MORRELL AYE BATES.
BATES HI CAM AERO.
CAM AERO I DRAWS -- MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE FIVE MORLOCK.
MORE LUCK I ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
NUMBER.
NUMBER I CASKEY.
OKAY THAT AS A VOTE SOMEONE FOR
ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU REMIND YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
OKAY NEXT WE'RE GONNA -- RETURNS
FOR EIGHTY TWO OR EIGHTY YOU
MARATHON FOR THE FINAL CHAPTER --
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN IS
HERE FOR ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT SB SIX SEVENTY ONE THERE
WERE THREE BILLS AND EIGHTY
THREE FOUR YEARS SOMEONE NUMBER
SO YOU -- WE EXPECT SOME REALLY
EXHILARATING PRESENTATION TO US.
TO THE CHALLENGE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER I HAVE
A VERY LONG POWER POINT ABOUT
THE BENEFITS OF EIGHTY USE.
START TO LEAVE HIM WITH THAT --
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR WORK WITH US
ON THIS LEGISLATION AND I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUT ONE ON PAGE FOR
THE ANALYSIS. TO ALLEVIATE
FLEXIBILITY CONCERNS BROUGHT BY
LOCALS SO YOU'VE ALL HEARD TODAY
I'M SURE OVER AND OVER AGAIN
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT EIGHTY USE
ARE AND HOW WHAT A WONDERFUL
TOOL THEY ARE.
AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS ASKS
ARE LOCALITIES TO THINK ABOUT
EIGHTY USE IN TERMS OF THE WAYS
TO HELP FOSTER PUBLIC PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SO IN LOS ANGELES THE AVERAGE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NIT WAS
RUNNING AROUND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A UNIT RIGHT
NOW GIVEN LAND COSTS AND ALL OF
THE OTHER OSTS OF BUILDING.
IT EIGHTY YOU CAN BE BUILT FOR A
FRACTION OF THAT COST PLUS
YOU'RE UTILIZING PRIVATELY OWNED
LAND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
AS REQUIRE LOCALITIES TO PLAN
FOR AFFORDABLE EIGHTY USE.
CAN BE LOW INCOME IT CAN BE
MODERATE BUT LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
PARTNER WITH THE WITH CITIZENS
TO SAY.
IT WILL YOU'LL LET US AS A CITY
TO INVEST IN YOUR PROPERTY WE
DON'T TELL THEM HOW TO DO THAT
WE COULD ASK THEM TO COME UP
WITH THAT THEMSELVES.
WILL HELP YOU BUILD THE EIGHTY
USES AN AXE AND IN EXCHANGE YOU
WRITE YOUR EIGHTY YOU IS AN
AFFORDABLE OR LOW INCOME HOUSING
FOR X. AMOUNT OF TIME.
IT'S A BARGAIN FOR THE FOR THE
CITY -- IT GETS PEOPLE INTO A
MUCH NEEDED HOUSING AND FOR MANY
HOMEOWNERS WILL BE THE ONLY
THING THAT WILL HELP WILL ALLOW
THEM TO BUILD EIGHTY YOU BECAUSE
THEY THEMSELVES MIGHT BE OF
MODERATE MEANS OR MODERATE
INCOME IN THIS IS A WAY THAT
THEY CAN PARTICIPATE.
IN EIGHTY USE AS WELL SO WE
THINK IT'S A WIN WIN FOR
LOCALITIES IT'S CREATING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT A FRACTION
OF THE COST.
AND HOPEFULLY CREATING A MORE
EIGHTY USE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND I DON'T THINK I HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE ARE WE SUPPOSED TO
SAY -- I WE DO HAVE A WITNESS
HERE.
WHO'S NOT HERE -- BUT HE WAS
GOING TO TO TALK ABOUT HOW GREAT
THIS LEGISLATION WAS HE WAS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WHOSE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
AND WITHOUT I WOULD REQUEST
FULLY REQUEST AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- IS THERE
ANY -- SUPPORT OF TESTIMONY
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
TODD DAVE ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
AND LUIS BRONTE WITH CALIFORNIAN
BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY ROOM MOTION BY SENATOR ROTH
AND ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS THIS BILL HAS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION IT'S RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT WITH THAT I
WOULD REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS A MIDDLE SIX SEVENTY ONE
BY SOMEONE NUMBER FRIEDMAN
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER HI
WIENER I MORAL.
MORRELL AYE BATES AYE CARRERO
[inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MORLOCK.
MORE LIKE I ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
UMBERG [inaudible]
BECAUSE HE SIX ZERO SIX CODE
SOMEONE PUT THAT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OKAY NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
SIX NINETY FOUR SOME MEMBER
IRWIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND ARE YOU.
HAVE THE COMING GO A FEW TIMES
WE APPRECIATE AND WELCOME BACK
PROBLEM -- THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS EIGHTY SIX NINE FOUR AN
AXE THE VETERANS HOUSING AND
HOMELESS PREVENTION BOND ACTIVE.
TWENTY NINETEEN TO AUTHORIZE THE
ISSUANCE OF BONDS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING WAS SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR VETERANS.
I CALIFORNIA'S VOTERS HAVE A
TWICE APPROVED THE VETERANS BOND
ACT AUTHORIZING GENERAL
OBLIGATIONS INTENDED TO HELP
VETERANS PURCHASE SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES FARMS AND MOBILE HOMES.
OVER FOUR ROUNDS OF FUNDED IN
OVER FOUR ROUNDS OF FUNDING THE
V. H. H. P. HAS PROVIDED NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED TOTAL
HOUSING UNITS FOR VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
OTHERS NOW ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION REMAINING -- FOR
V. H. H. P. AT A RATE OF SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION PER ROUND THAT
FUNDING WILL RUN OUT IN. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TO GET A BOND ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT THE BILL
WILL HAVE TO PASS THIS YEAR OR
WITH AN URGENCY CLAUSE NEXT YEAR.
THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED TWELVE
THOUSAND HOMELESS VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN MORE
EXPERIENCING HOUSING AND
SECURITY ARE STRUGGLING TO MEET
MAKE ENDS MEET AND TRANSITION.
ACCORDING TO AGE CD
APPROXIMATELY 79% OF CALIFORNIA
VETERANS WHO RENT OR SPENDING
MORE THAN 50% OF THEIR INCOME ON
HOUSING.
AB SIX NINE FULL FOR WILL ASSIST
VETERANS WHO ARE HOMELESS OR WHO
NEED AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING
TO SECURE HOUSING FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
STRICTLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS GREG HE'S
HERE BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF VETERANS SERVICE
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM
IS HELP BUILD DIED IN THE TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED HOUSING UNITS FOR
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
IT'S VERY SUCCESSFUL WE HOPE YOU
AUTHORIZED TO CONTINUE THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
COULD BE SEEN NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. THREE NINE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
OUR MOTION BY SENATOR ROSS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
MORE LOCK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SIMPLY WOMAN IRWIN WHERE WILL
THE MONEY COME FROM TO PAY THE
BOUGHT.
THE MONEY FROM THIS IS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND [inaudible]
SO.
I DIDN'T SEE AN AND THE STAFF
REPORT HOW MUCH THAT WOULD COST
PER YEAR -- I I CAN GET BACK TO
YOU WITH THE THAT AMOUNT IS LIKE
I SAID THIS IS BEEN APPROVED BY
THE VOTERS TWICE ALREADY SO THAT
INFORMATION IS CERTAINLY THERE I
DON'T HAVE IT AT MY FINGERTIPS
NO I DON'T THAT'S FINE USUALLY.
WHEN WE HAVE A BOND?
ISSUE -- WE WE GET LIKE A NICE
PRINT OUT OF THE CREDIT RATINGS
AND ALL THE REST -- SO IT WASN'T
IN THE STAFF REPORT DID.
CALIFORNIA IS.
OF THE TEN LARGEST STATES THAT
BOX THAT USED TO GIVE US SHOWS
US THAT WERE THE WHO ARE THE
THIRD LOWEST RATED STATE FOR
ISSUING.
BONDS AND ARE.
GET PER CAPITA IS THE THIRD
HIGHEST.
IN THE NATION AND AND ALL THE
DATA IS IS RATHER.
ILLUMINATING THAT YOU KNOW WHERE
WE'RE AT AND SO -- I I'M SORT OF
A PERSON WHO SAYS IT IN USING
SAYS VETERANS I'M THERE IT'S
LIKE IT'S LIKE.
THE GOLD STANDARD BUT I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT.
IF THIS GETS ON THE BALLOT AND
IT WILL PASS BECAUSE PEOPLE VOTE
FOR VETERANS AND AND THEN WE
HAVE -- A CLIMATE CHANGE BOND
AND WE HAVE A IN OTHER PARTS
BOND AND AND WE HAVE ALL THESE
IS IT AND ANOTHER BOND -- FOR
THE THE THE UNIVERSITY'S SEE
ISSUE AND YOU SEE.
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT.
HOW DO WE PAY FOR ALL THAT?
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE THE VOTERS.
THEY OWN THANK ABOUT THAT THAT'S
OUR JOB TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO PAY
FOR TALK.
I I I WILL BE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL SO FORGIVE ME BUT IT'S IT'S
I WANT TO BE CONSISTENT WITH MY
OTHER NO VOTES ON BOND MEASURES
BECAUSE I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT.
HOW IT ALL GETS PAID BECAUSE
IT'S KIND OF IT'S IT'S GONNA
SQUEEZE OUT OUR GENERAL FUND?
AND DO WHAT WE GONNA GIVE UP TO
MAKE THESE PAYMENTS AND THAT'S
MY DILEMMA.
AND I JUST WANTED.
TO LET YOU KNOW SO YOU CAN
REVIEW WHAT'S AND WHY'S ONE
GUIDE OF THE NO GUY AND THAT'S
THAT'S WHY.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS ARE SITTING ON WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR ROSS
AND WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
AS FOR AYE VOTE WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS AN ABLE SIX TWENTY FOUR
BY FROM THE NUMBER IRWIN MOTIONS
TO PASS AND REFER THE COMMITTEE
ON VETERANS AFFAIRS.
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER I MORAL STATE
[inaudible]
IT'S KERO [inaudible]
DORADO.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE NO ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
UMBERG -- CASKEY.
THE CURRENT LOTUS THREE TO ONE
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
OKAY NEXT -- WILL -- GO TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WORKS WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND SENATORS I WANT TO THANK --
THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THE CENTER FOR ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD ON THIS
ISSUE.
AND FOR THE VERY STAKEHOLDERS WE
HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS AND I
WANT TO START BY -- I'D LIKE TO
AMEND EIGHTY FORTY FIVE WITH THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE LAID OUT AND
COMMENT FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
AB FORTY FIVE ALL US CITIES TO
STREAMLINE MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT WHEN THEY DO
NOT MEET THEIR READ AND NUMBERS.
FOR THIS SPECIFIC INCOME LEVEL
THESE -- IT'S BASICALLY
EXPANDING EXISTING STREAMLINING
OF FOR THAT MATTER INCOME AND
THIS IS REALLY AIMED AT
EXPANDING OPPORTUNITY FOR WHAT
WE CALL THE MISSING MIDDLE THOSE
THAT DON'T.
QUALIFY FOR SUBSIDIES HOUSING
BUT DON'T MAKE ENOUGH FOR FOR
MARKET RATE -- ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL WILL CLOSE LOOPHOLES THAT
HAVE ARISEN SINCE SB THIRTY
FIVES IMPLEMENTATION WHICH WE'VE
LEARNED AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH
THE PROCESS.
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED IN THE
ORIGINAL SB THIRTY FIVE
AGREEMENT AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS --
MICHAEL LANE REPRESENTING
SILICON VALLEY AT HOME I SHOULD
ALSO THIS BILL HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY BILL
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND ON THE
FLOOR -- AND HAS A WIDE ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED -- IN THIS
IN TERMS OF SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION --
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY BEAR
COUNCIL AND MANY MANY OTHERS.
AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO MY AREA.
MY WITNESS HERE.
BUT SURE WINNER MEMBERS
MICHELENA SILICON VALLEY AT HOME
THE THE GOAL IS LEGISLATION TO
PROVIDE HMES FOR MODERATE
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
EARN TO MUCH FOR SUBSIDIZE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT NOT
ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO COMPETE IN
THE MARKET CURRENTLY -- FOR
MARKET RATE HOUSING IN
PARTICULAR AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE WILL CREATE A PATH TO
PRODUCE THIS TYPE OF BELOW
MARKET RATE HOUSING WITHOUT
DIVERTING FINITE AND PRECIOUS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RESOURCES --
TO HIGHER AND HIGHER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS -- IS THAT WE CAN
FOCUS THOSE THOSE PRECIOUS
DOLLARS ON LOWER INCOME AND MORE
DEEPLY INCOME TARGETED UNITS WE
THINK OVER TIME STREAMLINED FOR
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING WILL BE
THE PREFERRED.
POLICY APPROACH A WAY TO DEAL
WITH THIS ISSUE AND WE ARE DRIVE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT I JUST
WANTED THERE WAS IS AN ANALYSIS
FOR THE MOMENT ONE SMALL TYPO IN --
IN BE. FIVE AFTER -- OF THOSE
PROGRAM SHALL -- IT SHOULD SAY
IT SAYS TO BE TREATED AS A TO
NOT BE TREATED SERVICES
TYPOGRAPHICAL ERROR.
IN THE ANALYSIS.
OKAY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA PROPERTY COMPANY
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY AND TMZ
PARTNERS ON SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BURIAL IN CHECK CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN CALIFORNIA
SOCIAIS SHOULD LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE HAVE THE
BILL.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THAT
ALLOWS FOR MODERATE INCOME
FINANCING TO HOUSING AUTHORITIES
AS A PILOT PROGRAM.
AND WE'VE BEEN UNABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE
FROM THERE SO MANY BARRIERS TO
DEVELOPING MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING.
WE COULD REALLY USE THIS TO PASS
OUR BILL.
LOUIS MANTE WITH CALIFORNIA BE
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
GOV ALL WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THE ROW WITH ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
HANNAH FAILING WITH THE TWO
HUNDRED AND SUPPORT.
THIS ORDER THE SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
TODD DAVID THERE A HOUSING
OFFICE HE COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
IN ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY WILL BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE EMOTION BY -- CENTER
ROSS AND I'VE FOR SOMEONE A I
THANK YOU SO MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
ON IS THE AUTHOR OF US SENATE
BILL THIRTY FIVE BACK IN --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT'S SOMETHING
I CARE A LOT ABOUT MAKING SURE
THIS BILL -- CAN ACHIEVE ALL OF
ITS POTENTIAL AND WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS GOING TO HELP A LOT AND
SO I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE AND
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THANK YOU SENATOR.
YES I'M IN CENTER MCGUIRE HAS.
A COMMENT OR QUESTION NO I I
OPPOSE IT COULD COME AT COLLEGES
IS HERE AND I APOLOGIZE THIS IN
THE WOMAN SINCE THIS IS GOING TO
COME AND GIVE THEM FIVE OR CAN
BE WORKING ON IT IT'S NOT AT ALL
IN REGARDS TO THE ISSUE OF THE
AUTHOR BUT JUST.
GONNA BE I'D NOT VOTING FOR THE
BILL TODAY AS WE CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE WE NEGOTIATE OF THE
BILL'S HIS RATES I THINK IT IS
SOMETHING WOMAN.
AND LOOK.
FOR TO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE PROBLEM ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SO -- WE
DO HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR ROTH
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU -- WE WILL OF THE
SERVICES ARE IN AYE
RECOMMENDATION AND WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS IS ON THE BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER
WICKS THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
SENATOR WIENER HI WIENER AYE
MORROW.
HI MORRELL AYE BATES BATES AYE
CABALLERO [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MOORLACH.
OUR LUCK AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
UMBERG -- CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE I SIX ZERO I'LL TAKE
IT AND HE PUT YOUR PUT YOUR OVER
THE TOP SIX ZERO BUT ON AUG ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OKAY AND
JUST IN TIME WE'LL GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB -- FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHU WHO WILL THEN WILL GO AFTER
THAT TO AND SEVENTEEN WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATORS -- AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN IS A REGIONAL BAY AREA
BILL TO ADDRESS A HOUSING CRISIS
IN OUR BEER A REGION.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S A REGION THAT
WAS AND CONTINUES TO BE THE
EPICENTER OF OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS WITH RECORD HOME PRICES.
RECORD RENTS RECORD EVICTIONS
AND RECORD LEVELS OF
HOMELESSNESS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE INDIVIDUAL
EFFORTS OF A HUNDRED AND ONE BAY
AREA CITIES AND NINE COUNTIES
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS
THE CRISIS PARTICULARLY AFTER
MANY SAW HOUSING STAFF.
AND FUNDING GOT IT AROUND THE
REGION AFTER THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT.
THIS BILL WOULD ENABLE THE BAY
AREA TO HELP ITSELF GIVEN THE
NINE COUNTY REGION THE AUTHORITY
TO RAISE FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SIMILAR TO HOW THE REGION HAS
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO RAISE
FUNDS FOR TRANSPORTATION AND FOR
RESTORATION OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY.
THE BILL WOULD ALLOW THE REGION
TO ASSIST LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN
PLANNING FOR PRODUCTION
PRESERVATION AND PROTECTION
ASSEMBLE PARCELS AND MONITOR
REGIONAL PROGRESS.
THE BILL SPECIFIES THAT THE
REGION WOULD FIGURE OUT ITS OWN
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE COMPOSED OF
MEMBERS FROM THE REGION'S
EXISTING GOVERNANCE BODIES THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
AS WELL AS THE ASSOCIATION OF
BAY AREA GOVERNMENTS AND TO SEE
IN A BACK.
THE BILL PROVIDES A REGION WITH
A RANGE OF FUND RAISING TOOL.
AND ENABLES REGION TO DETERMINE
WHICH REVENUE MEASURES TO PLACE
ON THE BALLOT FOR VOTER APPROVAL.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH REGIONAL LEADERS TO
DETERMINE THE BEST WAY TO
DISTRIBUTE AND EXPEND FUNDS.
INCLUDING AN EXISTING WORKING
GROUP SET UP BY THE REGIONAL
AGENCIES SPECIFICALLY TO PROVIDE
INPUT ON THIS LEGISLATION THAT'S
EXPECTED TO PROVIDE INPUT BY TE
END OF THIS MONTH.
THE BEER IS HOUSING CRISIS
THREATENS NOT ONLY THE BAY AREA
BUT MAJOR ECONOMIC DRIVERS OF
THE STATE THIS BILL WOULD
EMPOWER OUR REGION TO FIND THE
ADDRESS OUR REGIONAL HOUSING
CRISIS.
WITHOUT PAYMENT A TURN IT OVER
TO OUR WITNESSES.
GREAT -- SO TO WITNESSES OKAY SO --
WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO THREE MINUTES EACH
THANK YOU.
HI I'M GET THE ROW AND I'M WITH
THE AND THE PRICE CAN YOU
PARTNERS AND WE'RE DELIGHTED TO
BE CO SPONSORING THIS BILL --
OUR MISSION IS TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES THROUGH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND LAST YEAR I CO
AUTHORED THIS REPORT IT'S CALLED
ELEPHANT IN THE REGION.
TURNING THE PATH FOR BAY AREA
METRO TO LEAD A BOLD REGIONAL
HOUSING AGENDA.
IN IN THIS REPORT WE LOOKED AT
HOW OTHER REGIONS ARE ADDRESSING
THEIR HOUSING AND THEIR
DISPLACEMENT CRISIS.
AND THE KEY FINDING FROM OTHER
REGIONS THAT ARE DOING IT WHILE
IS THAT THERE IS A ROBUST
HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
TWO COMPONENTS OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE NUMBER ONE IS
FUNDING.
AND THE SECOND IS THE CAPACITY
TO ADMINISTER EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS
AND POLICIES AND DEPLOY
INNOVATIVE FINANCING.
WE'RE INVESTED IN THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT'S THE FIRST STEP TO
BUILDING THE REGIONAL HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE NEED IN
THE BAY AREA.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE RELIED ON
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO SOLVE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
AND SO MANY LOCAL HOUSING
DEPARTMENTS THEY'VE BANNED
ESSENTIALLY GUIDED SINCE THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES.
THERE SIMPLY ISN'T ENOUGH OF
FUNDING AND THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
STAFF FOR EXPERTISE.
THIS BILLS AWAY TO HELP
JURISDICTIONS.
IT'S ALL CARROTS IT'S FUNDING
IT'S TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IT'S
HELP WITH LAND ASSEMBLY AND DATA
CREDIT TRACK TRACKING.
THERE ARE NO STICKS OF OF
EMINENT DOMAIN OR OR YOU OUR
LAND USE AUTHORITY. FOR THE PAST
YEAR WE'VE BEEN ENGAGING ON
HOUSING DEPARTMENT AND PLANNING
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE BAY AREA
AND WE'VE ASKED HIM HOW CAN THIS
BILL HELP YOU.
AND THESE ARE THE EXAMPLES THAT
THEY PROVIDED AND OUR PRICE.
WHEN THE NEXT NATURAL DISASTER
HITS DEPLOYING REGIONAL FUNDING
TO REBUILD HOMES AND COMMUNITIES?
LAND ASSEMBLY TOOLS TO HELP WITH
ACTIVATING PUBLIC LAND FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND HOUSING EXPERTISE THAT CAN
HELP CREATE EFFECTIVE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FOR THOSE
FAMILIES THAT ARE FACING
DISPLACEMENT -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO MENTION THE AD HOC COMMITTEE.
AND THE INTENT OF THAT IS TO
FIGURE OUT THE RIGHT GOVERNANCE
AND TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE NOT
CREATING ANOTHER REGIONAL AGENCY.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY A SET OF
TOOLS TO RAISE FUNDS AND TO
ENSURE REGIONAL COORDINATION TO
ADDRESS THE WORST HOUSING CRISIS
IN THE COUNTRY.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND WE DRAPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE WINNER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PATRICK OUT PHONE
WITH THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE FORTY YEAR OLD FOR DOUBLE
HOUSING ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
THAT BELIEVES THAT EVERYONE IN
THE BAY AREA SHOULD HAVE AN
AFFORDABLE AND STABLE PLACE TO
CALL HOME.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WILL MOVE US MUCH
CLOSER INTO MAKING THAT VISION A
REALITY -- BY PROVIDING REGION
SPECIFIC BY ADDRESSING A REGION
SPECIFIC HOUSING NEEDS BY
DEVELOPING YOU FUNDING AND
PROGRAMS.
AND SO AB FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN
AS I MENTION WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL YOU FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THE THREE PIECE OF HOUSING
SPECIFICALLY -- TEN PROTECTIONS
HOUSING PRESERVATION AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION --
AS YOU ALL KNOW WITH THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT IN
TWENTY TWELVE WE HAVE WE SAW A
HUGE.
AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FUNDING VANISHING TO ENTERTAIN
AIR IN THE BAY AREA ALONE WE
LOST ABOUT A QUARTER BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN DEDICATED
FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WILL MAKE THAT -- WILL HELP US
RECOUP SOME OF THOSE LOSSES.
THIS IS THESE ARE SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE WIDELY SUPPORTED BY BAY AREA
RESIDENTS IN POLLING THAT WAS
CONDUCTED BY EMC RESEARCH IN
LATE APRIL -- THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT AMONG VOTERS
82% AGREE THAT THEY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED FAMILIES BEING
ABLE TO FIND AN AFFORDABLE PLACE
TO LIVE. THREE OUT OF FUR
VOTERS AGREED THAT WE NEED TO
REGIONAL APPROACH TO HOUSING
THAT IN THE BAY AREA NOT SIMPLY
CITY BY CITY POLICIES.
AND THE SENTIMENT IS WIDESPREAD
GEOGRAPHICALLY IT WITH AGREEMENT
ABOVE A MAJORITY IN EVERY COUNTY
AND ABOVE 70% IN ALAMEDA MARIN
SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN MATTEO
CONTRA COSTA AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTIES.
THE RESEARCH SHOWED AND
OVERWHELMING CONCERN AND THAT
79% OF FOUR YOUNG OF YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS.
BEING FORCED TO LEAVE THE STATE
DUE.
TO OVERWHELMING HOUSING COSTS.
AND SO.
I DON'T HAVE MUCH TO ADD MORE TO
THE TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL OTHER THAN THAT THIS WILL
PROVIDE MORE CRITICALLY NEEDED
FUNDING COORDINATION ACROSS THE
BAY AREA.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
MIKE LEMON SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME IN STRONG SUPPORT. TO DAVID
BAY AREA HOUSING I'M SIXTY
COALITION SUPPORT.
ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY SKEWS ME ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
OF THE EAST BAY SILICON VALLEY
AS WELL AS HIM TO PARTNERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MELISSA WARNER THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LOUIS MANTE WITH CALIFORNIA
INDIANS TRANSPORT -- ANYMORE ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
NICCOLO DELUCA HERE BEHALF OF
TWO MAYORS HE'LL TO MAYOR LIBBY
SCHAAF IN SUPPORT OF THE OF AND
THEN THE BERKELEY MARRIAGES HERE
AGAIN IN SUPPORT APPRECIATE.
ALL THE CHANGES AT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN HIS OFFICE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON SO THANK YOU.
CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
SAY NON WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
COLLEAGUES CENTER WHAT CAL SKI
[inaudible]
THE I GUESS THE CONCERN IS THE
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF THE
FUNDS -- INNOVATIVE ALAMEDA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
HAS LODGED IN OPPOSITE
OPPOSITION THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT 50% OF THE MONEY BEING
REGIONAL THERE'S THAT
EXPECTATION OR ARE BEING
DISTRIBUTED.
REGIONALLY ALSO HAVING A BAG AS
A HAVE A LARGER SHARE -- NONE OF
THESE NINETY THERE'S NO
AMENDMENTS SO AS WONDER IF YOU
COULD.
ANSWER THAT CONCERN THE PEOPLE
HAVE SINCE I DON'T REPRESENT THE
SITTING COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO SAN
AT WERE OAKLAND SO I HAVE
WORRIED ABOUT THOSE OTHER
SMALLER CITIES.
SO WILL ANSWER THE QUESTION IN
TWO SEPARATE WAYS THERE REALLY
ISSUES RUN GOVERNANCE OF WHO
RUNS IT AND THEN THERE'S THE
ISSUE OF OF WHERE THE MONEY GOES.
SO AS FAR AS A GOVERNANCE ISSUE --
WE HAVE -- WE HAVE ESSENTIALLY
SUGGESTED THAT A COMMITTEE OF
MTC IN A BAG THAT IS MEETING AB
WE SPEAK THEY WORK OUT WHAT THEY
THINK IS APPROPRIATE GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE. TO THEN BE PROPOSED
TO MISTER REQUIRES COMMITTEE AND
THAT'S THE HOPE OF WORKING THIS
OUT IN THE CHALLENGES SO WE
EXPLAINED -- THE MTC AS WE KNOW --
IS VIEWED AS BEING A BIT MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OF LARGER CITIES
A BAG IS BEING VIEWED AS A BIT
MORE REPRESENTATIVE OF SMALLER
SUBURBAN CITIES IT'S SORT OF
LIKE ASKING THE HOUSE AND SENATE.
IN CONGRESS TO KIND OF FIGURE
OUT HOW TO BEST FIGURE THIS OUT
THAT'S A WE'VE ASKED THEM TO DO
WHEN THEY COME OUT BACK WE WILL.
VERY LIKELY ASKED TO ADOPT THAT
A MISTER REQUIRES COMMITTEE AS
FAR AS WHERE THE MONEY'S GOING
TO OF THIS IS ALSO BEEN -- AN
ONGOING DIALOGUE WITH DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS -- THERE ARE A LOT
OF JURISDICTIONS THAT WOULD LIKE
AS MUCH MONEY TO RETURN TO
SOURCE AS POSSIBLE -- AND THAT
WOULD PREFER TO SEE YOU KNOW
MORE THAN 75% OF THE MONEY GOING
BACK TO THE ORIGINAL COUNTIES
WHERE THE MONEY'S REGENERATOR
FROM.
ON THE OTHER HAND I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT THE AFORDABLE
HOUSING COMMUNITY AND CITIES
THAT ARE READY TO BILL TODAY
WOULD PREFER THERE TO BE A
REGIONAL POT SO FOR EXAMPLE
NUMBER CLOSER 250%.
WE DECIDED TO HIT THE BALL DOWN
THE MIDDLE BY PROPOSING THAT 75%
OF THE MONEY RETURNED BACK TO
THE COUNTIES -- BUT THAT.
QUESTION IS ALSO BEING LOOKED AT
VERY CAREFULLY AT THIS MOMENT BY
AND TO SEE IN A BAG AND AGAIN
WE'RE EXPECTING POTENTIALLY SOME
MORE NUANCED.
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THAT AREA SO --
THAT'S THE DETAILED ANSWER THANK
YOU [inaudible]
REQUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO TALK
WITH THE SOMEONE OVER THERE
TODAY WE CAN BE GETTING TOGETHER
TOMORROW TO GET A TALK ABOUT
GETTING TO BILLS -- FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THREE IN NO IN THIS AND THAT WE
DISCUSSED HERE TODAY AT SINCE
WERE.
HAVING THOSE OPEN CONVERSATIONS
LIKE I SAY THERE ARE VERY FEW
PEOPLE ARE AS GOOD AS A SENT
OVER THERE TO WORK WITH I AM
VERY GRATEFUL FOR ALL HIS HARD
WORK -- GOING TO BE.
NOT VOTING ON BOTH OF THE BILL
SO WE CAN WORK THIS OUT PRIOR TO
GETTING CONFERENCE IN FINANCE
AND APPRECIATE ALL HIS HARD WORK.
OKAY OFTEN -- CABALLERO.
PADRES FOR MISSING -- PART OF
THE PRESENTATION BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE LATEST THE
X. EXPLANATION THE TICKET RIGHT
NOW ENTERED THE TURN TO THE
GOVERNMENT -- IN REAP REALIZE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO GO OVERTO
ANOTHER COMMITTEE IN THE IN THE
SENATE -- THAT'S PROBABLY WHERE
I WOULD HAVE FOCUSED A LOT OF MY
QUESTIONS ON BUT I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE WE WERE CREATING
ANOTHER ENTITY.
THAT ON THAT DAY THEN -- READ
YOU KNOW COMES UP WITH THE WITH
THE PLAN AND HOW THE MONEY
SHOULD BE SPENT AND THEN.
PAYS THEMSELVES RIGHT WE WANT AS
MUCH MONEY AS POSSIBLE GOING
TOWARDS THE CREATION AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SO I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT'S WORK AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE.
IT WHEN SHE'S YOU GENERATE
REVENUE WHERE IT GOES BECOMES A
REAL CHALLENGE REGIONALLY SO HI
I'M I MEAN IT'S PRETTY BILL
TODAY AND WE'LL SEE HOW IT COMES
OUT OF THE NEXT COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE.
BUDGET THAT THANK YOU.
CENTER MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THE SEVEN CHIU IN ORANGE COUNTY
WE HAVE -- SEE COG ORANGE COUNTY
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS.
AND IT'S A SUB REGIONAL PLANNING
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THE SUPERVISORS AND THIRTY
FOUR CITIES ARE ABOUT.
THERE'S ALSO THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS RECALLS GAG ALSO
REGIONAL.
HOW WOULD YOUR PROPOSAL COMPARED
TO THOSE TWO IF YOU IF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THEM?
SO I'M I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
SPECIFICS OF YOUR ORANGE COUNTY
ENTITIES BUT WHEN I REFER TO
SOME OF THE BAY AREA ACRONYMS OF
A BAG AN MTC.
THOSE ARE TWO REGIONAL BODIES --
THAT REPRESENT CITIES BUT IN
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT WAYS -- AND
THE MTC IS KNOWN AS BEING A
LITTLE BIT MORE REPRESENTATIVE
OF LARGER MORE URBAN CITIES IN A
BAG IS A BIT MORE REPRESENTATIVE
OF SMALLER SUBURBAN CITIES.
WHAT I WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE
BASS THOSE TWO ENTITIES TO WORK
TOGETHER ON A JOINT COMMITTEE TO
PROPOSE FINAL AMENDMENTS TO THIS
BILL?
SO WHAT I REFER TO AS THAT
PROCESS -- IT SHOULD COME TO A
CLOSE IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS IN
TIME TO PUT AMENDMENTS INTO --
CENTER MAGUIRE'S COMMITTEE FOR
FOR CONSIDERATION BUT THE IDEA
IS TO REALLY MERGE ALL OF THOSE --
THOSE INTERESTS TOGETHER -- THE
OTHER THING I WANT TO SAY AND I
AND THIS PARTIALLY RESPONSE TO
CENTER COPIERS POINT WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO ESTABLISH AN ENTIRELY
NEW ENTITY IF WE CAN AT ALL --
ACHIEVE THAT -- RIGHT NOW A BAG
AND TO SEE OR ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS POTENTIALLY TO
MERGE SOME OF THEIR FUNCTIONS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE HOUSING
ISSUES BUT THE REALITY IS WE DO
NOT HAVE AN ENTITY.
IN THE BAY AREA THAT IS FOCUSED
ON HOUSING AND THE WAY THAT WE
NEED TO WE DON'T HAVE AN ENTITY
IN THE BAY AREA.
THAT CAN ALLOW US TO REALLY
PROVIDE THE SELF HELP ME THAT WE
NEED TO DO.
IN THE WAY THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
IN THE BAY AREA WHEN IT COMES TO
TRANSPORTATION AND SAN FRANCISCO
BAY RESTORATION AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR WITH THIS BILL.
AND I WAS MT A AND EIGHT MTC
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND AB A BAG IS A
CESSATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS.
BECAUSE HE CAN'T HAVE ENOUGH --
ACRONYMS YEAH NO I'M I'M GONNA
DO SOME RESEARCH ON THAT.
DO YOU KNOW HOW THEY WERE FORM
WHERE THEY DONE THROUGH
LEGISLATION OR WERE THEY JUST
TODAY THEY DOES THAT.
MEAN -- SERVE OUR AND SO -- SO
THE MTC -- IS THE MPO
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATION FOR THE BAY AREA --
WHICH HAS HISTORICALLY FOCUSED
ON TRANSPORTATION A BA IS THE
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS OKAY I
THINK IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THEY TEND TO BE COMBINED.
INTO ONE ENTITY AND THE AND THE
BAY AREA -- THEY'VE NOT BEEN
WHICH HAS CAUSED SOME.
CHALLENGES AND REDUNDANCY AND SO
THAT'S WHY THE TWO ORGANIZATIONS
ARE -- DISPENSED.
A SEMI MERGER OF STAFF -- AND SO --
WE STILL AS WE OFTEN DO WE DO A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY IN THE IN
THE BAY AREA -- AND I APOLOGIZE
RESTRICT TRYING TO GET THE
CONTEXT BECAUSE I I SEE.
A HUNDRED ONE CITIES WHICH IS
PHENOMENAL IT'S THAT BIG DUMB.
AS HE NINE COUNTIES THAT'S
THAT'S AN AMAZING.
TASK BUT I DON'T SEE THEM ON THE
LIST OF SUPPORTERS SO I'VE.
I WOULD EXPECT TO SEE A COUPLE
PAGES OF CITY NAMES.
AND SO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE IT
OUT -- SO WHY NOT BE A VOLUNTARY
JPA AS OPPOSED.
TO COMING HERE.
SO.
THIS CAME OUT OF A OF A BROAD
BASED REGIONAL PROCESS -- AND
AND THIS IS ONE OF A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS -- I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
CARRYING THIS PARTICULAR -- ONE
AND AND SO IT DOES HAVE A LOT OF
SUPPORT BUT AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF POLITICS
AROUND.
A HOUSING IN THE BAY AREA AND SO
IT'S IT'S COMPLEMENT IT'S
COMPLICATED -- BUT THERE IS A
LOT OF SUPPORT FOR THIS IDEA I
THINK WHAT I WOULD SAY ALSO SAY
YOU DON'T SEE THE CITY'S
INDIVIDUALLY BEING LISTED AS
SUPPORTERS YOUR OPPONENTS
BECAUSE THEY ARE WORKING THROUGH
EITHER A BACKER THE MTC.
AND SO THEY'RE WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE TO TO US TO CENTER
MCGUIRE -- TO CONSIDER FOR THE
NEXT COMMITTEE.
AND THAT NEXT MEDIA'S GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE CORRECT SO I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU'RE GOING TO GET TO
MCGUIRE BUT BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
COMMENT ON THAT.
STATE OUT OF THAT.
ONE BUT I I WILL DO SOME
RESEARCH IN THE MEANTIME SO I
CAN GET.
YOU KNOW COMPARISON BASED ON MY
PERSON AT THE STATE -- BECAUSE A
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT ARE WE
CREATING A NEW BUREAUCRACY WHICH
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A GOOD
IDEA OR OR SOCIAL IF YOU GET IF
YOU HAVE SOME.
ANSWER THE QUESTION AROUND THE
IDEA OF ANY BUREAUCRACY IT IS
NOT OUR INTENT TO CREATE A NEW
BUREAUCRACY -- IT IS OUR HOPE
THAT -- POTENTIALLY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT COULD GET GET
SUBSUMED UNDER WHAT -- YOUR YOUR
CHAIRMAN HAS DESCRIBED AS THE
THE MERGING OF AND TO SEE AN A
BACK WE ALSO HAVE IN THIS BILL A
LIMITATION ON ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS OF 3% SO ANOTHER IS 97%.
OF ALL THE FUNDING THAT IS REYES
THROUGH THIS WOULD GO OUT TO
COUNTIES.
OUT TO CITIES TO BE USED FOR
ADDRESSING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS TO THAT WAS ONE
WAY WHICH WE REALLY CAP TO
ENSURE WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
CREATE A BIG BUREAUCRACY THAT'S
THE LAST THING THAT I WANT TO DO
HERE -- BUT WE ARE GIVING THE
pITSELF BECAUSE OF THE SIZE OF
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS
AND I WOULD SAY TO MEMBERS AND
SENATORS WHO DO NOT REPRESENT.
THE BAY AREA AN ADVANTAGE OF
SUPPORTING THIS BILL IS IF WE
ARE SUCCESSFUL THE BAY AREA AT
HELPING TO ADDRESS OUR FORTY
HOUSING CRISIS.
WE WOULD CREATE LESS OF A BURDEN
OR COMPETITION FOR DOLLARS ON
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS THAT THAN
OTHER PARTS THE STATE WOULD
WOULD HAVE -- BETTER ACCESS TO
SO THAT IS ANOTHER.
SUGGESTION AS TO WHY HOPE YOU
MIGHT SUPPORT THIS BILL AS OUR
SO PROBABLY LATE OFF TODAY AND
THEN.
DO SOME MORE RESEARCH FOR
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE AND IF
CENTER REQUIRED DOESN'T GIVE YOU
ENOUGH PUSH BACK LET ME KNOW ALL
HELP OUT.
WELCOME TO HOUSING COMMITTEE IS.
AGAIN NO COMMENT ON THAT
COLLOQUY [inaudible]
OKAY -- SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU.
ARM IT IS SOMEONE NUMBER TWO
WHAT IS THE AND YOU MAY HAVE
ALREADY DISCUSSED THIS BUT IN
SEE IN THE ANALYSIS BUT IS THERE
A LIMITATION IN THE BILL ON THE
PERCENT OF FUNDS THAT CAN BE
USED FOR STAFFORD MINISTRATION.
WE JUST I JUST MENTION IT TO US
AND WE'RE LIKE 3%.
AND THAT STAFF TO THIS IS ALL
ADMINISTRATIVE I'M JUST LOOKING
MY STUFF ALL MINISTRY EXPENSES
STAFF INCLUDED.
OKAY BECAUSE THE THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL SHOWS THAT THEY CAN USE
SEVENTY CNA BACK STAFF BUT THEY
CAN ALSO HIRE STAFF AND SO --
BEGIN MIGHT -- WHEN THIS CONCEPT
WAS FIRST PROPOSED BY THE FOLKS
IN THE BAY AREA WHO WERE ON?
COMING UP WITH THE A WHOLE HOST
OF POLICIES THAT COULD HELP
ADDRESS OUR HOUSING CRISIS.
THIS IS THE ONE THAT I WAS THE
MOST SKEPTICAL ABOUT BECAUSE I
FELT THAT.
WE DON'T NEED TO CREATE A NEW
BUREAUCRACY THAT WHILE YES
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE ENTITY FOR
HOUSING IN THE BAY AREA THERE
ARE CERTAINLY -- EVERY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DOES HAVE ITS
RESPONSIBILITY AND UNDER LOTS OF
STATE LAWS WHETHER THEY ARE
MEETING THOSE OR NOT IS A
DIFFERENT STORY BUT THEY DO HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY.
AND I WAS CONCERNED THAT BY THE
TIME SOMETHING NEW GOT
ESTABLISHED AND THEN MONEY WAS
COOL I MEAN THAT YEAH YOU KNOW
THOUSAND CRISIS IS NOW.
IT'S NOT A AT FIVE YEARS FROM
NOW.
AND CONSTRUCTION TAKES SO LONG
SO -- I HAVE BEEN DEEPLY
SKEPTICAL I WAS ALSO THE WAY IT
WAS EVER NATIONALLY PRESENTED
NOT THE LANGUAGE IN YOUR BILL
THAT.
PERHAPS THE SALES TAX MEASURE
WHICH I COMPLETELY OPPOSE FOR
THIS PURPOSE BECAUSE SALES TAX
IS ONE OF THE MOST REGRESSIVE.
TAX MEASURES AND IT IS THOSE
PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE MOST HIT BY
SALES TAX WHO SUPPOSEDLY MIGHT
BENEFIT FROM.
THIS -- IS THE FINANCING
AUTHORITY THAT THIS WOULD CREATE.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
POTENTIALLY OTHER -- REVENUE
MEASURES THAT ARE BEING
CONSIDERED AND I UNDERSTAND ALSO
THAT SALES TAXES BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM THIS -- I STILL HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT REVENUE
MEASURES WOULD BE -- PURSUED ON
LET ME SAY MORTON CONCERNS I'D
SAY RATHER THAT I HAVE BIASES AS
TO WHICH I THINK SHOULD BE AND
WHICH SHOULDN'T -- BUT BY THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS WERE
GIVING THE AUTHORITY TO THAT
INTO DE DETERMINED THAT AND OF
COURSE THEN THE VOTERS TO
APPROVE BUT BECAUSE I DO REALIZE
THAT WE NEED.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOURCES
ESPECIALLY IN THE BAY AREA
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST COST OF CONSTRUCTION
OF ANYWHERE -- THAT.
IF YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL WAYS TO
GENERATE REVENUE IN ORDER TO
COVER THE COSTS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
IS A LEGITIMATE.
ISSUE SO I WILL -- LOOK FORWARD
TO SOME GOOD AMENDMENTS IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE THAT ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CITIES IN AREAS CONCERNS --
AND I WILL -- WHAT I CALL IT I
WILL DO A WILLING SUSPENSION OF?
DISBELIEF IN TERMS OF WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN WITH THIS AND SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY IN TERMS OF THE
CONCERNS I'VE HAD IN THE PAST.
OKAY -- SEEN OTHER COMMENTS I
JUST WANNA AGAIN THANK THE
SUMMER FOR CARRYING THIS BILL --
ANYTHING LIKE THIS IS GOING TO
BE OF SOME OF ALL CONTROVERSY SO
APPRECIATE YOUR MOVING THROUGH
THAT.
I WOULD APPRECIATE IT IF YOU --
AS YOU MOVE TO THE GOVERNOR TO
FINANCE COMMITTEE BECAUSE KEEP
OUR HOUSING COMMITTEE STUFF IN
THE LOOP -- ON THIS -- BILL --
AND IN PARTICULAR I KNOW THAT
THERE IS A PUSH I SEE IN A
LETTER FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION FOR
EXAMPLE -- WHICH I'M SURE --
REFLECTS THE VIEWS OF THE SMALL
CITIES ARE NOT ALL BUT MANY OF
THE SMALL CITIES IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
BOB BASICALLY PUSHING TO SHIP
THIS OF THE SMALL CITIES WOULD
MAKE ALL THE DECISIONS ABOUT IT --
THERE AND SO THAT THE FEES WOULD
BE GENERALLY PAID BY THE BIG
CITIES AND THEN SPENT ON THE
SMALL CITIES AND NOT REALLY
RIDICULOUS -- MEMONS HAS TO BE
QUITE FRANK AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE GO THROUGH
THE MEMBER PROCESS -- THAT --
THAT.
KIND OF THINKING DOESN'T GET ON
MOMENTUM -- THERE ARE SOME WHO --
IT'S IN THE BAY AREA US IN THE
SMALLER -- CITIES -- THAT ARE
MORE BEDROOM COMMUNITIES -- WILL
POINT TO THE BIG CITIES LIKE
OAKLAND SAN FRANCISCO.
AND SAID IT'S ALL YOUR FAULT FOR
CREATING A LOT OF JOBS -- AND
WE'RE GOOD BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
CREATE A LOT OF JOBS AND OF
HOUSING -- BUT OF COURSE THERE
RESIDENTS WORK IN THE CITY'S --
THAT HAVE JOBS AND SO I THINK WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT HIS REGIONALLY --
AMPLE WITH A COPY OUGHT -- THE
SUCH ENJOYING AYE RECOMMENDATION.
AND WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION ON THIS I
KNOW THIS IS HARD.
WE'RE IN A CRISIS AND SO THE
IDEA IS HOW CAN WE AS A REGION
THAT WE HEAR FROM MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE COLLEAGUES OUTSIDE
OF THE REGION WHY CAN'T WE HELP
OURSELVES IN ADDRESSING.
THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE AND THAT'S
THE POINT OF OF THIS BILL TO
GIVE THE REGION THE ABILITY TO
TO SORT OF DETERMINE OUR FATE
AND HOPEFULLY -- DO WHAT WE NEED
TO DO -- TO LIFT OURSELVES OUT
OF THE CRISIS AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU TO
SOLVE OUR STATE HOUSING CRISIS
SO.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS OUTLOOK FOR TWO
ASSUMING THIS MOVES FOR FROM
THIS COMMITTEE -- THE CONTINUE
CONVERSATION BUT CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGE WITH ALL OF
YOU ON THIS AND WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE CENTER
LIKE CAL SKI AS HE WAS WALKING
OUT MADE A MOTION SO WE HAVE A
MOTION MY CENTER LIKE HEALTHY --
AND WITHOUT -- WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ON THE BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BASED ON THE NUMBER
TOO MUCH IS DUE PASSED REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORROW.
NO BATES.
BATES NO CARRIER.
CARRIER I DRAWS -- TERRAZZO I
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I AM BURKE.
CASKEY.
OKAY YOU HAVE FIVE VOTES TOTALLY.
FIVE TWO TWO FIVE TWO WILL PUT
THAT ON A CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL NOW GO
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF FIRST I WANT
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MOMENTS
AND APPRECIATE -- YOU YOUR
FEEDBACK AND STAFF FEEDBACK ON
THEM -- THIS IS A BILL THAT IN
THE MIDST OF OUR HOUSING CRISIS
WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DENSITY
BONUSES FOR A 100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS.
OR BILL IS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS A
FEW CHALLENGES FIRST THE FACT
THAT ZONING IS OFTEN A BARRIER
TO HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
AND EXISTING ZONING.
IS OFTEN TOO LOW FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS TO PENCIL OUT.
CERTAINLY WE ALL KNOW HOW SCARCE
FOR WHAT HOUSING FUNDING AS AND
WE NEED TO STRETCH EVERY DOLLAR
TO BUILD MORE UNITS -- THE THIRD
CHALLENGE WE ARE TRYING TO
ASSIST THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER COMMUNITY WITH IS IN
COMPETING WITH MARKET RATE
DEVELOPERS. FOR LAND WHERE WE
KNOW MORE DENSITY CAN HELP MAKE
A PROJECT FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE
AND GIVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS HOW 2% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR ADDITIONAL DENSITY
BONUSES ABOVE EXISTING ZONING
DENSITY.
AND GIVEN THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
EQUITY BENEFITS OF LOCATING
HOUSING YOUR TRANSIT A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
YOUR TRANSIT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR UNLIMITED DENSITY BONUSES
PLUS AN INCREASE IN FIGHT OR
FLOOR AREA RATIO IS.
UP TO A LIMIT -- AND WITH THAT
WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESS -- MISTER APRIL.
THANK YOU SIMPLY NUMBER TWO MY
NAME IS RAY PEARL.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM.
I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
GIVING ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT A BILL.
AB.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE AT C. H.
C. HAS BEEN PROUD TO SPONSOR.
SEE EACH YEAR THE NONPARTISAN
ADVOCATE FOR THE PRODUCTION
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. TO LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
WE HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO ON THIS BILL
AND WE HAVE APPRECIATED WORKING
WITH YOU TO CENTER WIENER.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO REDUCE
OBSTACLES TO BUILDING A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
THESE ARE PROJECTS WERE EVERY
SINGLE UNIT REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HOUSE A
CALIFORNIA FAMILY.
THAT CAN A POOR AFFORD TO PAY
RISING RENTS.
THE BILL WOULD HELP MAKE MORE OF
THESE PROJECTS POSSIBLE.
AND AT LOWER COSTS.
WITH HOUSING PRICES AND RENTS
ONLY GOING UP WE KNOW HOW
DESPERATELY LEGISLATION LIKE
THIS IS NEEDED.
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE OF
IN SOME OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
BIGGEST CHAMPIONS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND YOU KNOW WELL THAT IN SPITE
OF ALL THAT WE HAVE ACCOMPLISHED
TOGETHER CALIFORNIA FOR STILL
FACES A SHORTAGE OF ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION.
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOMES.
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT PART
OF CLOSING THAT GAP.
IT WILL DIRECTLY RESULTED MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BEING BUILT.
FOR THE CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED IT
MOST.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND SIGNIFICANT LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA THANK YOU MISTER PEARL
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBERS JULIE SNYDER
WITH EQUITY ADVOCATES
REPRESENTING HOUSING CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL EMISORA CONDO AT HOME IS
STRONG SUPPORT.
ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY IN SUPPORT.
KAREN LÏNG ON BEHALF OF THE
BURBANK HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION IN SUPPORT.
ON OUR WITH THE WESTERN FROM A
PARTY IN SUPPORT.
TODAY THE BAY AREA HOUSING UP TO
SEE COALITION SUPPORT.
MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF A SAN
DIEGO MAYOR KEVIN FAULCONER IN
THE ENTIRE CITY COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
BRIAN GOT SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
BRAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FILL THE INSULATION ON BEHALF OF
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
LOUIS FRONT AND WE HAVE OF
CALIFORNIAN B. AND SUPPORT WE
WERE LATE IN GETTING OUR LETTER
AND BUT THAT'LL BE INSTANCE ARE.
YOU THROW IN A PRESS CAN YOU
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
MARILYN J. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OKAY OPPOSITION. FOR TWENTY
YEARS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHASE RILEY CALIFORNIA
CITIES -- WE HAVE AN APOSTLE
ESTIMATE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
WE'RE HOPING I'M TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS YOU HAD WITH THE
SPONSORS.
AND THE OTHER STAFF.
WE DO AGREE THAT WHEN YOU TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT AS A BONUS LAW THEN
PERHAPS WE NEED TO ADJUST IT --
IS 80% YOU KNOW THE RIGHT NUMBER
HOW TO GET SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW WORK WORDS STILL
LOOKING AT I THINK WE'RE WE HAVE
CONCERNS IS THE UNLIMITED
DENSITY ANY ADDITIONAL HEIGHTS.
AROUND TRAIN STOPS AND BUS STOPS
AND BUS CORRIDORS AND WE'VE HAD
THOSE CONCERNS WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER BILLS.
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH -- THESE
COMMITTEES AND WE HAVEN'T QUITE
LANDED AS A LEGISLATURE AND AS A
NO STAKEHOLDERS ON WHAT THE
RIGHT SOLUTION IS.
AND WE CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE.
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION AND
TAKE A MORE HOLISTIC LOOK AT
WHAT SHOULD STAY GOALS BE AROUND
TRAINS AND BUS STOPS AND BOWS
CORRIDORS -- AND WE WOULD HAVE
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT YOU'RE
SEPARATED I'M FROM THIS MEASURE
BUT WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN HIS SPONSORS AND AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THERE --
BECAUSE DANCING ABOUT A
CERTAINLY IS A VERY POWERFUL
TOOL AND IF YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A
100% AFFORDABLE PROJECT YOU
PROBABLY SHOULD GET A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
IN WITH THAT WITH RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE LAST MINUTE.
AN ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
AFTERNOON CURE ROSS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF BURBANK IN SAN
MARCOS ACT WHEN THE CONCERNS THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES.
JOHNSON CLAIMED THAT THE CITY
EVEN SENATORS ALSO IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
OKAY SIGNAL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE -- MOTION BY SENATOR
ROSS AND CENTER MORE LOOK.
THANK YOU RESEARCHER I JUST HAD --
QUICK QUESTION AND THAT IS --
WHAT WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT PARKING --
IT WELL WE ARE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE MINUTES ABOUT
ELIMINATING PARKING FOR SPECIAL
NEEDS HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSING IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
QUESTIONS ABOUT I APOLOGIZE.
FOR SOME CHIU WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT PARKING IN FIRE SAFETY
CONCERNS AND CONGESTION AND
STREETS AND ALL THE REST AND I I
I I SHOULD HAVE PRACTICED IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE I APOLOGIZE.
I'VE BEEN IMMERSED TODAY AND WE
WERE JUST WONDERING ALSO WHY
JASON HASN'T BEEN HERE ONCE
UNTIL NOW.
SO THERE'S NOTHING IN THE BILL
EXCEPT FOR WHAT I JUST MENTION
AS FAR AS THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT HAVE TO DO A PARKING SO
SPECIFICALLY.
THE BILL WELL THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING FROM THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD ELIMINATE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS FOR SPECIAL
NEEDS HOUSING AND SUPPORT OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS -- THAT
MAKE A 100% OF THE UNITS
AFFORDABLE TO LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND OBVIOUSLY THE THE
THE IDEAS FOR THOSE PARTICULAR --
COMMUNITY SOME PROJECTS --
PARKING IS LESS NECESSARY.
THANK YOU IN.
DO YOU HAVE ANY RESPONSE.
NO I WOULD I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THE THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE THE
THE THE PARKING SITUATION WITHIN
SEE BONUS LAW -- YOU KNOW NAY
EVERY IF IT IF AT A DEVELOPER IS
GOING TO AGREE TO A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF VENOM RAVEN HUSBAND ME
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
AFFORDABILITY THAN THEIR SOME
CONCESSIONS BUT THE PARKING WITH
INTENSITY BONES Là CERTAINLY
REASONABLE.
AND AND WE WOULDN'T OBJECT -- TO
THE COMMITTEES MOMENT.
THANK YOU.
AND IF THE CAR BY SINCE THE
MOMENT TO COME FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT
LIMITED SUBSET OF HOUSING -- THE
THE CHANCES OF THOSE RESIDENTS
ARE GOING -- TO ON A CAR IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER -- AND TO
IMPOSE THAT KIND OF DRAMATIC
COST.
ON TO THESE PROJECTS FOR A
POPULATION IT'S MUCH LESS LIKELY
TO HAVE A CAR -- JUST DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE BUT IT'S A VERY
NARROW SUBSET OF THESE PROJECTS.
ANY ADDITIONAL CENTER CABALLERO.
VERY MUCH -- I'VE BEEN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A COUPLE OF THINGS --
IN ARE GENERALLY -- TRIED TO
STAY AWAY FROM A 100% AFFORDABLE
UNITS BECAUSE OF THE OVER
CONCENTRATION THAT CAN OCCUR
WHEN YOU PUTTING -- A LOT OF
POOR PEOPLE ON ONE PLACE TO HAVE
A SIZE LIMITATION IN TERMS OF OF
YOUR CONCEPT OF OF AND THEN LET
ME JUST PREFACE IT BY SAYING.
I SUPPORT.
ALL THE DIFFERENT ELEMENTS THAT
YOU HAVE IN YOUR BILL I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
NUMBER ONE IF IF THERE'S IF
THERE IS IF YOU ANTICIPATE SOME
SIZE LIMITATION ON THE ON THE
SIZE OF A PROJECT NUMBER.
ONE NUMBER TWO IS.
IF YOU'VE THOUGHT ABOUT HOW THIS
WORKS WITH CITIES THAT HAVE
EXISTING DENSE -- INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING ORDINANCES WHICH
SOMETIMES INCLUDE DENSITY
BONUSES IF YOU'RE BUILDING
AFFORDABLE UNITS AS WELL -- AND
THEN ALSO THE IMPACT ON REAL
COMMUNITY SO THAT THE THREE THE
THREE THINGS THAT I WAS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT AND I'M NOT SURE I
HAVE AN ANSWER SO I'M WONDERING
IF YOU DO.
SO CENTER I'LL TAKE ONE OF THOSE
DEALS WITH THE THE TYPE OF
CONSTRUCTION.
AND ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT THE
CHASE AND BROUGHT UP ABOUT.
THE HEIGHT.
OF THE BULK OF WHAT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
BUILD IS STICK CONSTRUCTION
VERSUS STEEL CONSTRUCTION AND
WHAT THAT ESSENTIALLY MEANS IS
MOST EFFICIENT USE OF THE LAND
IN A 1100% AFFORDABLE PROJECT.
IS GOING TO BE FIVE TORIES ARE
LESS.
AND SO THAT IS A VERY BIG
COMPONENT OF WHAT OUR DEVELOPERS
LOOK LOOK LOOK.
FOR AND AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
MENTIONED PART OF WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS ALLOW.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO
COMPETE WITH MARKET RATE
DEVELOPERS MAKING IT A MUCH MORE
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD ON THE TYPE
OF HOUSING THAT'S GOING TO BE
BUILT IN THE TRANS.
AND IF I COULD ANSWER.
A COUPLE OF YOUR OTHER PIECES
THE QUESTION SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT STRUCTURES DDITIONAL
DENSITY UNLESS YOU'RE NEAR MAJOR
TRANSIT IN WHICH CASE WE LATER
ON MORE SO.
WE TRY TO SCULPTED -- DEPENDING
THE AREA SO THAT WOULD MEAN IN A
RURAL AREA YOU COULD RECEIVE A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF DENSITY BUT NOT
THE MORE THE THE T. MORE
SIGNIFICANT DENSITY THAT YOU
WOULD IF YOU WERE IN AN URBAN
AREA SO THAT'S A PARTIAL ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION -- YOU ALSO
ASKED ABOUT -- YOUR PERSPECTIVE
WHICH I SHARE THAT WE WHERE
POSSIBLE WOULD NOT WANT -- TO
OVER CONCENTRATE -- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- AND I THINK IDEALLY
THAT WOULD BE THE CASE BUT WE
ALL KNOW THAT -- THAT'S EASIER
SAID THAN DONE ONE AMENDMENT
THAT WE HAVE TAKEN AT THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTION WHICH WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO DO.
IS TO ALLOW.
FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF MODERATE
INCOME WORKFORCE HOUSING
PROJECTS -- TO RECEIVE THE
DENSITY BONUSES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SO WE'RE NOT JUST
TALKING ABOUT A 100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN SOME INSTANCES TO
PAYER THE DENSITY BONUS THAT IS
ENHANCED THROUGH THIS BILL WITH
ARE MIXED INCOME LOAN PROGRAM AT
CAL HFA.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW FOR MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING TO BENEFIT FROM
THE DENSITIES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SO THAT WAS AN AMENDMENT
THAT -- THE CHAIRED ASKED FOR IN
A VERY GOOD SUGGESTION.
THAT'S GREAT SO SO THE REASON I
ASKED ABOUT RURAL COMMUNITIES IS
THAT THE HIGHEST ENTITIES ITS
ALLOWED IN -- IN.
SALINAS I CAN SPEAK TO THE
SALINAS IN THE SALINAS VALLEY
AND I WANT TO SAY PROBABLY SAN
BENITO COUNTY IT'S REACHED THREE
STORIES AND IF YOU DRIVE AROUND
YOU WON'T SEE ANYTHING THAT'S A
THREE STORY.
APARTMENT BUILDING THAT I CAN
THINK OF AND SO.
SO OF IT GOING TO FIVE BECOMES
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER DENSITY
THAN THAN WHAT WOULD NORMALLY BE
SO THAT'S THE REASON FOR THAT.
IS THERE A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
URBAN AND RURAL AND DO YOU HAVE
A ARE YOU GONNA BE ROLLING --
RURAL COMMUNITY SAID THAT MOVING
21100% AFFORDABLE BUT THE OTHER
ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH --
INCLUSION OR HOW HOUSING
ORDINANCES BECAUSE SOME OF THEM --
ALLOW THE DENSITY BONUS.
AT THE ROOT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
IF YOU ARE BUILDING AFFORDABLE
UNITS AS PART OF YOUR PROJECT
AND SO HOW DOES THIS WORK THIS
ONE TRUMP THE OTHER OR DO ARE
THEY CUMULATIVE I GUESS IS THE
QUESTION BECAUSE WE'VE HAD THIS
ROBLEM.
BEFORE WITH OUR DEN WITH OUR
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING ORDINANCES
BEING OVERRIDDEN BY STATE LAW
THAT LOOKED LIKE THEY WERE
GIVING AN EXTRA DENSITY BONUS ON
TOP OF EVERYTHING ELSE.
WHEN I WAS MY CHIEF CONSULTANT
TO YOU HAVE AN INCLUSIONARY
ORDNANCE THEN THE INCLUSIONARY
IS COUNTED WITHIN THE DENSITY
BONUS SO IT'S NOT CUMULATIVE
OKAY [inaudible]
GREAT.
OKAY WELL THE THAT THAT THE REAL
ISSUE IS HAS ME A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED BUT FRANKLY IF YOU
GIVE US MONEY TO BUILD --
TRANSPORTATION CENTERS AND I
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
INCREASE IN THE DEBT SEX WE JUST
NEVER GET THE MONEY -- AND
THAT'S A SUBJECT OF AN EPIC
ANOTHER COMES UP AND WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT.
TOO OKAY -- SEE NO OTHER
COMMENTS I ALSO JUST WANT TO
KNOW -- IN TERMS OF THE
CONCENTRATION ISSUE -- CENTER
COMING AIR RAIDS.
EVEN -- THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
AMENDMENT FOR THE KEY -- TO ONE
TWENTY MODERATE INCOME --
CATEGORY BUT EVEN UP 280% OF THE
AMOUNT AM I EVEN THOUGH WE
THAT'S GENERALLY CATEGORIZED
SAYS SOME LEVEL OF LOW INCOME
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT SOMEONE
WHO'S A 607080% OF AM I
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE IN
THE STATE THAT COULD BE SOMEONE
MAKING.
FORTY OR FIFTY OR SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE VERY MUCH A PART OF OF WHAT
WE WOULD CONSIDER CLASSIC --
QUOTE UNQUOTE WORKING CLASS --
SO IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT -- THE
THE LOWEST INCOME PEOPLE TO IT'S
A REAL MIX REGARDLESS.
GREAT -- SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BY CENTER ROTH AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
JUST AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION AND HOUSE FOR A
VOTE -- WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS AN ABLE SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THREE BASED ON THE NUMBER TO
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED IN
REFER THE COMMITTEE AND
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE SENATOR
WIENER HI WIENER I MORAL
[inaudible]
BATES.
CARO.
CARO I DRAWS -- MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
ARMONK I ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
I'M BURKE.
CASKEY. FORTY SIX VOTERS FOUR
ZERO WILL PUT THE ITEM ON CALL
THANK YOU SIR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY AND THEN LAST BUT CERTAINLY
NOT LEAST -- WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- GARCIA HERE FOR ITEM
FIFTEEN AB.
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M GOING TO TRY TO BE BRIEF.
GOT SOME IS BACK TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE LIKE THE REST OF A
STRANGE DEVELOPED ALL -- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE IT WOULD
REQUIRE A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HOUSING ELEMENT. TO INCLUDE AN
ANALYSIS OF GOVERNMENTAL
CONSTRUCTION -- CONSTRAINTS.
PROVIDE HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS
IN THAT A FIVE UNDER THE UNDER
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT WERE
PROTECTED -- CLASSES.
OFTENTIMES AS WE DO YOU POLICIES
WE HAVE.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
SOMETIMES THEY MIGHT BE INTENDED
AND MAYBE NOT THE RIGHT
INTENTION.
OUT THRE IS ALWAYS WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE ARE.
TALKING ABOUT HOUSE SCENE THAT
WE ARE THINKING ABOUT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ON OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES OVER TIME
YOU ARE MODIFIED RELATIONS RULES
POLICIES ACTIONS ORDINANCES.
AND OTHER PLANNING AND ZONING
REQUIREMENTS BY CITIES AND
COUNTIES HAVE LED TO INCREASE
HOUSING COSTS.
THIS INCREASED COST HAVE HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE BEING MINDFUL OF THESE
COMMUNITIES ALONG THE WAY.
MICHAEL DINING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IS HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THIS GERMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU
MICHAEL DOWNING HERE WITH C. B.
I A REPRESENTING THE OVER --
THREE THOUSAND HOME BUILDERS AND
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD MOST OF THE
SINGLE FAMILY HOUSING IN THE
STATE -- IN SUPPORT AND
SPONSORING THE BILL.
I THINK THE AUTHOR HAS STATED
THE PURPOSE HERE THAT SOMETIMES
HE'S LOCAL ORDINANCES DO HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE EFFECT ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
MINORITIES PARTICULARLY AS WE
LOOK BACK IN THE HISTORY OF
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE THOUGHT THIS AN
APPROPRIATE MEASURE THAT SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED AND NURTURE
SUPPORT THANK YOU -- GERMAN MY
NAME IS ROBERT ABA DHAKA I'M
WITH CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THE BUILDERS.
BOB MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS
WAS FORMED.
TO CLOSE THE WEALTH GAP FROM THE
U. S. THROUGH HOMEOWNERSHIP WERE
MOST CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
UP TWELVE CAP AMONG -- PERSONS
OF COLOR.
WE HAVE A ADVOCACY GROUP CALLED
THE TWO HUNDRED AND IF SO
STATEWIDE COALITION OF ETHNIC
MINORITY LEADER CIVIL RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS CIVIC LEADERS IN PEACE
IN COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AND WE'RE ADVOCATING FOR
INCREASED HOUSING PRODUCTION.
THAT ALL INCOME LEVELS -- AS A
SPONSOR OF OF THIS BILL ALONG
WITH -- CALIFORNIA -- CBO CBI.
AND ALSO COR AND THE YEN BEES --
I'M HERE THIS AFTERNOON TO
SUPPORT AB FIFTY SIX WANTS BONTA
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA.
NEWMAN MODIFIED HOUSING
REGULATIONS WITH OTHER
LEGISLATIVE AND IMPLEMENTED BY
CITIES AND COUNTIES REGARDLESS
OF INTENT.
OF THE NEW VERSIONS OF REDLINING
TO CONTRIBUTE TO KEEPING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FROM
ACCOMPLISHING THE AMERICAN DREAM.
THAT IS HOMEOWNERSHIP.
THE ENTIRE FAMILY IS AFFECTED
BUT CHILDREN SUFFER THE MOST BY
NOT HAVING ACCESS TO QUALITY
EDUCATION HEALTH CARE.
HEALTH FOOD OPTIONS PARTS AMONG
THE BENEFITS RELATED TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP -- THE TWO HUNDRED
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE
BECAUSE IT IS CONSISTENT WITH
EXISTING LAW AND PARTICULAR AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERS FOR HOUSING.
THAT IS PROTECTED BY THE FOR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
THE FOR ABOUT REASON WE ASK THAT
YOU.
UP APPROVED A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY
ONE AND ALSO APPROVAL OF THAT
LEGISLATION TO INCREASE HOUSING
PRODUCTION FOR ALL FAMILIES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON LUIS BRONTE WITH
CALIFORNIAN BE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HOLLY FOR MANY ON BEHALF OF SAND
HILL PROPERTIES IN SUPPORT.
STILL VEHICLE TO ARE YOU ARE IN
FOR THE TWO HUNDRED AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION. THREE
NUMBER IMPACT THE COMMITTEES
SENATOR ROTH MOVES A BILL.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES.
BUT YES ANNA CABALLERO.
SO I'M I A REALLY APPRECIATE
[inaudible]
THAT -- THE PURPOSE AND I GUESS
I'M I'M AT THE RIGHT THINK WE
UNIVERSALLY APPEAR EVERYBODY
AGREES THAT INCREASE PRODUCTION
IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW YOU WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING.
FOR AND I'M AND I'M A LITTLE
PARANOID ABOUT PUTTING ANYTHING
MORE.
IN GENERAL PLANS AND IN HOUSING
ELEMENTS.
THAT IS JUST MAKE WORK FOR
CITIES.
SOME TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
YOU'D BE LOOKING.
FOR IN IN IN.
IN THIS.
AT THE END IN THIS BILL IT'S
LIKE WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR
AND THEN HOW DOES IT GET
RESOLVED BECAUSE AB IT IT SEEMS
TO ME.
THIS IS MY VIEW OF THE WORLD IS
THAT.
WEALTHY COMMUNITIES EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO NOT BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T WANT
THOSE PEOPLE LIVING IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND AND AND AND EVEN IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE YOU HAVE --
ECONOMICALLY DIVERSE GROUPS --
EVERYBODY HAS THE SAME KIND OF
MANTRA WE DON'T WANT THOSEPEOPLE LIVING I OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD ALTHOUGH THEY ARE
ALREADY LIVING THERE THERE RIGHT
NEXT DOOR THEIR FOR THEIR PEOPLE
YOU KNOW ALL ANY THAT YOU SEE.
THERE THE PEOPLE THAT SERVE YOU
RIGHT SO SO HE TO DO IT CITY BY
CITY OR IT DOESN'T GET YOU WHERE
YOU WANT.
TO WANT TO GO HI I THINK.
WHAT WHAT WHAT GET TO WEAR THAT
THE ANALYSIS OF OUR IS THEIR
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES HOUSING
PRACTICES IS WHEN YOU LOOK ON A
REGIONAL BASIS?
WHERE ARE THERE VERY FEW PEOPLE
OF COLOR LIVING?
AND WHERE THEY'RE VERY FEW
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON CAN
MAINTAINING THE ECONOMY THAT ARE
THAT ARE.
THAT ARE UNDER THE THE MEDIAN
INCOME SO TO SPEAK OR DO THEY
LIVE AT NIGHT AND I'M WONDERING
HOW YOU GET THAT PUTTING THIS IN
INTO -- INTO A A DOCUMENT THAT
IS -- PART OF THAT PART OF WITH
A CITY PRODUCES AND THAT THEY
LOOK AT I'M I'M I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT.
MAY I THAT I JUST HE AND I AND
AND I REALLY RESPECT THE AUTHOR
AND THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT I THINK IT'S
GREAT I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW IT REALLY WORKS -- SO I
WILL SAY THAT YOU HAVE CITIES
THAT -- NY SAID AT THE BEGINNING
UNINTENDED THE FOR SOME FOLKS IT
IS AN INTENDED AND VERY INTENDED
POLICY.
THAT TRYING TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT
SO WE'RE ASKING THAT. FOR THOSE
THAT ARE UNINTENDED MAYBE THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ASKING THEMSELVES
THE QUESTION AND ASKING THEM
THOUSANDS OF THE QUESTION IS THE
FIRST STEP TOWARDS.
THEM HAVING MORE EQUITABLE
POLICIES IN DECISION MAKING I
TING FOR THOSE WERE AT IT IS
INTENDED MAYBE PUT IT OUT THERE.
IN WRITING MIGHT GIVE US MY
ALLOW FOLKS WHO LIKE TO WORK. TO
HELP THEM BE MORE EQUITABLE AND
HELP THEM WITH THE POSITION TO
THAT SPOT I THINK WE COULD LOOK
AT IT RECENTLY -- BUT I THINK AT
THE A DAY WE HAVE TO START
LOOKING AT WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE LOCAL LEVELS OF THE CITY'S
GET TO HAVE THEIR OWN ORDINANCE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO SOLVE
EVERYTHING -- AND IT'S JUST A
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE AND HIS
CLIENTS TRYING TO CALL ATTENTION.
I LOOK AT COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE --
AND THEN I LOOK AT NEIGHBORING
COMMITTEES LIKE MINE THAT ARE
BEING NEXT NEXT MY THAT ARE
BEING IDENTIFIED THAT WERE JUST
LIKE MINE AND WHO'S BEING PUSHED
OUT AS WE'RE BUILDING UP.
AS WERE REMODELING AS A SERENE
GENTRIFIED AND PEOPLE BEING
PUSHED OUT OUR PEOPLE I LOOK
LIKE MY COMMUNITY AND IT'S BEING
REPLACED BY.
MIDDLE CLASS FOLKS THAT LOOK
VERY DIFFERENTLY AND AND THERE'S
NOT THAT BALANCE AND I DO THINK.
THAT WELL I WANT THAT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT -- AND IN SOME GOOD
THINGS HAVE COME FROM FROM THAT
JUSTIFICATION WE NEED TO BE
ASKING THEMSELVES QUESTIONS IS
THAT IT'S JUST PRETENDING THAT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IT DOESN'T
EXIST BECAUSE TOO OFTEN WE DON'T
CARE ABOUT THE SMOKE SOMEWHERE.
INTENTIONAL AND UNINTENTIONAL AT
THAT PRACTICE [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
I'M HAVE HAVING SERVED ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND HAND THE
STARTING IN A REGIONAL GENERAL
PLAN -- INCORPORATED OUR
COMMUNITY THIS JUST SEEMS SO
COMPLICATED.
OUR APPROACH RATHER THAN JUST
REQUIRING IN A GENERAL PLAN THAT
YOU HAVE AN AX NUMBER OF UNITS
THAT ARE.
AFFORDABLE BECAUSE THE A FIFTY
AFFORDABILITY THAT MAKES THE
DIFFERENCE FOR PEOPLE LOW INCOME
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
IT'S ALL ABOUT AFFORDABILITY.
SO IF YOU HAVE THAT AS YOUR
MEASURE IT WOULD SEEM TO ME YOU
MEET THAT STANDARD BUT HAVING
SOME OF THE SUBSETS.
I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU HOW YOU
ACHIEVE THAT.
ANGIE AND I ARE ON THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE REQUIRED THAT WAS IN THE
EIGHTIES THEY REQUIRE 25%
AFFORDABLE THEY PUT A TWENTY
FIVE YEAR.
REQUIREMENT THAT THOSE REMAIN
AFFORDABLE AND I WILL TELL YOU
WHEN THAT CAME OFF -- THE THE
THE RUSH TO BUY SOME OF THOSE
HOMES BECAUSE IT WAS REQUIRED IN
THE COASTAL AREA.
ALONG THE BEACHES AS A MATTER OF
FACT THOSE THINGS SOLD LIKE
HOTCAKES AT MARKET RATES BY THAT
TIME IT WAS FOUR OR FIVE TIMES.
A WITH THE ORIGINAL OWNERS PAGE
SO THAT THERE WAS A YOU KNOW AN
AMAZING BONUS THAT WAS RECEIVED
SO.
THAT'S GOING TO COME DOWN TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL WHERE YOU
PUT THE THE REQUIREMENTS FOR A
LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY OF
AFFORDABILITY.
BUT IT YOU KNOW HOW LONG THEY
HAVE TO STATE AFFORDABLE VERSUS
THE MARKET RATE SO IT SEEMS TO
ME IF YOU WOULD REQUIRE AND A
GENERAL PLAN SOMETHING AS BROAD
AS YOU HAVE TO MAINTAIN AND
PURPOSE TO IT.
IN AFFORDABLE LEVEL -- FOR THE
VARIOUS INCOME LEVELS YOU KIND
OF SOLVE YOUR PROBLEM.
THE PUTTING SOME OF THESE OTHER
SUBSETS IN THERE I THINK THAT
WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT. FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO CHIEF
BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S GOING TO
HAVE A DIFFERENT PERCEPTION OF
THAT.
IN FROM COMMUNITY TO COMMUNITY
AND I SAW OME STATISTICS
RECENTLY WHERE.
STATES LIKE FOR EXAMPLE TEXAS
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE LOW INCOME OR
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THEY HAVE 51% HOMEOWNERSHIP
VERSUS WHAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA'S NEARLY 30% I THINK
IT'S SOMEWHERE AROUND 24%.
SO THERE ARE REGULATIONS THAT
ARE IN PLACE HERE IN TERMS OF
HOW YOU BUILD HOMES THAT ARE.
KEEPING PEOPLE OUT IN ITS ABOUT
THE AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS
THAT YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO PUT AN
END GENERAL PLAN.
SO A I'M I'M GONNA STAY OFF
TODAY BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE
WORKING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
BUT I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
SIMPLE IF YOU'RE GOING TO ASK --
IT BE COOKIE CUTTER FOR EVERY
GENERAL PLAN AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S DEVELOPED BY A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BE THAT A
COUNTY OR CITY.
GIVE THEM SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
WORKABLE AND THEN AT THE
MANDATING IT MAKES IT VERY GOOD.
BUT CHAU TO HELP BE SUBSETS I
THINK THAT -- IT DID VERY
DIFFICULT DIRECTION TO ASK THEM
TO GO IN AND I WILL SAY COSTS
THEM A LOT OF MONEY AND IT CAN
ELAY.
DELAY DELAY IN GETTING WHERE YOU
WANT TO GO.
CENTER MORE LUCK.
SORRY -- SOMEONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO RESPOND OR I MEAN I I WOULD
SAY THAT.
WE ARE JUST ASKING THAT THEY
ASKED THE QUESTION WE ARE NOT
ASKING THAT THEY CARVE OUT OR DO
ANY PERCENTAGES OF ANY SORT.
IN THEIR BILL THE FIRST STEP IS
THAT THE AFTER QUESTION AND
MAYBE IN ASKING THE QUESTION
THEY MIGHT DECIDE THAT.
THEY WANT TO ADDRESS THAT WHEN
THE WHEN THE OFFICE OF THE
QUESTION DO WE SEE THE SEVERITY
HERE MAYBE WE SHOULD ADDRESS IT.
BECAUSE THAT THERE BE AN
INTENTIONAL BUT THE QUESTIONS
BEING ASKED -- THE IDEA OF
HAVING -- QUOTAS AND HAVING THEM
BE FOR MEN IT IS WORTH THE IDEA
IF I THINK A DIFFERENT BLL FOR
SOMEONE ELSE TO WORK ON
INCLUDING YOURSELF AND SOMETHING
FOR YOU TO COME IN SALINAS
CITIES ABOUT.
I CENTER MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE SILLY
WOMAN GARCIA JUST.
TRYING TO I'M I'M STRUGGLING
LIKE CENTER CARRIER OF TRYING.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING ON IT
SEEMS TO ME YOU'RE READING
HISTORY.
YOU'RE LOOKING BACK AND SAYING
THIS IS THE EVOLUTION OF OUR
CITY.
AND WE WRITE IT DOWN.
AND THEN HOW DOES THAT CHANGE
EVERY FIVE DAY YEARS.
WHAT I DON'T KNOW THAT WHERE I
BEING IN ASKING THE QUESTION SO
HOW WE HAVE DONE AND IN HISTORY
HAVE WE DONE IT RIGHT AND WE
HAVE AND THEN A RIGHT CAN WE DO
IT BETTER?
I THINK WE GET A WE ARE ASKING
WE WILL THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
LIKE TO PRETEND THAT WE ARE
COLOR COLOR BLIND.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY IMPLICIT
BIAS OUT THERE -- AND AND THAT
WE LIVE IN A PRETTY EQUITABLE
SOCIETY ALREADY AND I THINK PART
OF WHAT I'M ASKING WITH THIS
BILL IS IS THAT THE REALITY WE
REALLY LIVE IN.
AND ASKING FOR THOUSAND SOUTH
SOME UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTIONS AT
TIMES WE DON'T WANT LIKE BECAUSE
OF THESE QUESTIONS.
BUT I'VE SEEN OUR SOUTH SOUTH OF
UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTIONS ALONG
THE WAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
UNCOMFORTABLE [inaudible]
SO I'M.
THERE IS A HISTORICAL.
ACTIVITY THAT GOES ON OLDER
HOUSING TRACKS TEND TO BE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT
HISTORICALLY THAT'S WHERE PEOPLE
TEND TO MOVE TO AND AND SOME.
TRYING TO SEE WHAT WOULD THERE
BE LIKE A A STANDARD FOR
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE ON HOW
CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS INVOLVED
AND THEN.
IF YOU DEVIATE FROM THAT THAT'S
WHERE YOU HAVE TO MAKE THE
CHANGE OF ONE OF MY MISSING
MISTER GUIDING.
ALL I I THINK IN ANSWER TO
CENTER BASE TO YOUR QUESTION I
THINK WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE HAS BEEN --
DISCRIMINATORY HISTORY IN THE
STATE WITH HOUSING AND IN FACT
MOST PLANS ALREADY INCLUDE LOW
VERY LOW ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BUT IT HASN'T BEEN MET BECAUSE
WE'RE AT THE CRISIS WERE AT NOW
I THINK WHAT THIS BILL **** FOR
IT AS THE AUTHOR SAID TO TO TAKE
A LOOK AT WHAT THOSE PATTERNS
HAVE BEEN AND TO ASK IF THIS NEW
HOUSING IS GOING.
TO CONTINUE THAT PATTERN.
I I THINK IT'S A IT'S A VERY
SIMPLE QUESTION THAT THAT THAT
CITY PLANNERS HAVE TO ASK
THEMSELVES.
HELLO SENATOR -- SKINNER IS
MENTIONED A BOOK A COUPLE TIMES
IN COMMITTEE ISOLATE.
WHO WOULD THAT BE COLOR OF LAW
SO SO THAT WOULD BE A HISTORICAL
OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU COULD?
USE IS A MIRROR THEN. THREE
SEVEN YEARS THIS APPROACH MISSES
WHAT YOUR CITY IS DONE AND
HERE'S WHERE THE SELF EVALUATION
OR REFLECTION.
SHOULD COLLECTIVELY COME FROM I
DON'T THINK I I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE CASE CENTER I THINK
WHAT THE BOOK DOES THIS POINT
OUT THE GOVERNMENT'S ROLE IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR ROLE IN THE
HOUSING PATTERNS WE HAVE IN THE
STATE.
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND SO AS A AS AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THAT HISTORY
AND GOING FORWARD WE'RE ASKING
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO LOOK AT
THEIR THEIR GENERAL PLANS AND
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT HAS HAPPENED
AND PREVENT IT FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN.
BEST OF THOUGHT.
BUT IF THEY LOOK AT IT AND THEY
DON'T SEE SOMETHING.
THAT MAYBE SOMEONE ELSE WOULD
WHO'S THE REFEREE TO HELP THEM
OUT AS ARE GONNA BE LIKE A COACH
THAT'LL.
HELP OUT OF THESE GENERAL PLANS
TO SAY WELL LOOK AT THIS POINTS
BY YOU.
TOTALLY MISSED IT.
I MEAN I WOULD SAY THAT CITIES
OFTEN ENGAGE IN PROCESSES THAT
ARE BUT WITH THE PUBLIC THAT ARE
WITH CONSULTANTS.
I TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE BEST
DO THIS AN ANSWER THIS QUESTION
AND GET THESE ANSWERS -- AND SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT.
I'M CONFIDENT CITIES WILL TRY TO
FIGURE OUT AND AND IF THEY DON'T
I'M CONFIDENT THAT HOPEFULLY IN
SOME OF THESE COMMUNITY STILL BE.
FOLKS WHO ARE ALERT AND AWARE
AND ARE GONNA SAY HEY THIS IS
NOT WITHIN THE SPREAD OF WHAT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING HEAVY
ASK YOURSELF.
THESE QUESTIONS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE NOT REPEATING
PATTERNS WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE LEARNING WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE TAKING THE LESSONS IN
THE BOOKS.
THAT ARE OUT THERE IN TRYING TO
SAY HOW CAN WE DO IT BETTER WE
ALSO IN LOSS EVERY HUMAN BEINGS
AND SO IT'S ARE GOING TO BE
PERFECT AND WE COULD HAVE THAT
CONTINUOUS.
SELF REFLECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER.
YES WOULD ALSO YOUR PREFERRED
HELL JUST VERY BRIEFLY.
I THINK I THINK TO OR TALKING
ABOUT IS IT.
NEW REGULATIONS -- WELL IN VERY
BE THE INCREASE THE COST OF
HOUSING.
AND SO.
THE INTENT MAY NOT BE TO
DISCRIMINATE.
BUT THE MORE YOU PILE ON THE
REGULATIONS.
BY DEFINITION.
THE COP THE COST GOES UP SO
THEIR FOR SOMEBODY WHO'S JUST
KIND OF MARGINAL.
THANK COULD LIVE IN A SUBURB.
IT'S NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO LIVE
THERE AND THAT'S DISCRIMINATORY.
SO THE EXAMPLE [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD.
HAS HE BEEN ON A LOT OF
REGULATIONS.
WHICH IS GOING TO MAKE IT VERY
VERY EXPENSIVE TO BUILD.
IN THE SUBURBS.
AND FOR THE REASON BECAUSE THE
THEY HAVE A NEW POLICIES CALLED
OF THE NET.
ZERO POLICY SO THAT EVERYTHING
IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE SOLD
ORDERS ALWAYS OTHER.
OF REQUIREMENTS THAT THAT --
THAT THE DETECTION TUNED
CALCULATIONS IN TERMS OF HOW
MANY MILES OUT HOUSEHOLDS GOING
TO DRIVE TO WORK AND SO FORTH SO
THEREFORE THE DEVELOPERS GOING
TO HAVE TO PAY.
IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO PAY.
FOR ALL THIS TRANSPORTATION US
AND THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL COST --
HAS TO GO IN THERE SO WHAT WAS
GOOD WHAT YOU THOUGHT WHAT'S
GOING TO BE A POSSIBLE IS NOT
GONNA BE POSSIBLE BOB.
THANK YOU MR ROBERT GOT BECAUSE
THAT YOU BRING UP.
THE REAL REASON WHAT WHAT WHERE
WERE TRêN TRYING TO DIG INTO SO
SO THAT YOUR PLANTS AS THANKS TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
THE FOLLOWING REGULATIONS.
AND IT CREATED THE PROBLEM WE
CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
[inaudible]
MY RUN.
I THANK YOU -- I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THIS --
LEGISLATION AYE -- SUPPORTED I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
IF YOU WOULD.
BE WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT -- AND
I I ACTUALLY DO THINK EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS A VERY IT'S A
VERY SIMPLE LOOKING BOTH VERY
STRAIGHT FORWARD IT'S IT'S NOT --
IS THAT IT'S NOT. FIVE LOOKS.
IT IS VERY STRONG FOR A LOT OF
WAYS I THINK IT WILL BE VERY
USEFUL.
FIRST OF ALL IT'S AS FORCING
CITIES WHEN THEY GO THROUGH
THEIR GENERAL PLAN HOUSING ON
THEM PROCESS. TO ACTUALLY.
GRAPPLE WITH THIS AND AND TO
THINK ABOUT -- AND TO TAKE.
AND AND TO BE.
ENGAGE IN SELF REFLECTION AND TO
BE INTENTIONAL ABOUT IT'S THAT
IN OF ITSELF AS A WIN.
I ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT --
GETTING CITIES TO ALLOW MORE
BILL MORE -- AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WE DON'T WE ALREADY.
REQUIRE THAT AND SOMETIMES IT
WORKS SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T.
BUT WE KNOW THAT CITIES WILL
SOMETIMES PUT ALL THEIR FORMAL
HOUSING IN JUST ONE AREA --
WHICH FROM ACTUALLY IT'S NOT
PERPETUATE SOME THESE PROBLEMS.
AND SO THEY'RE ALL SORTS OF
ISSUES THAT COULD BE -- SUGGESTS --
FROM ANTI WHAT KIND OF AND ITS
PLACE FROM PROTECTIONS ALLEN
PLAYS OWNING IT CETERA CETERA SO --
IN THIS IS A GOOD STEP AND ON
INTO IS AN AYE RECOMMENDATION --
WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR ROTH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I'M GONNA BE BRIEF -- WE AT THE
STATE PASSED POLICIES THAT HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES -- AND
I'M GONNA DISAGREE A LITTLE BIT
WITH WHAT I MY WITNESSES AND
STUFF THAT.
ARE A DISTRICT THAT'S TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINUS IMPORTED
AS WELL -- I LIVE IN ONE OF THE
MOST TOXIC COMMUNITY THING YOU
GUYS HAVE TO HEAR ABOUT.
THE TOXICITY TO THE VILLAGE THAT
KERRY AND SO I'M NOT SAYING THAT
IT DOESN'T ADD ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT ALONG THE WAY.
BY -- I I DO WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THAT.
BUT WE SHOULD BE ASKING
OURSELVES INTENTIONAL QUESTIONS
AMERICAN TO BE INCLUDING THAT
THEIR DISTRICT ABOUT HOW WE ARE
HELPING OR HURTING.
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
COMMUNITIES ARE THIS ADVANTAGE.
ALONG THE WAY AND ALL I'M ASKING
HERE IS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WERE
INTENTIONAL AND I WILL SAY THIS
I WILL USE ONE OF MY SERVICE AS
AN EXAMPLE. 70% OF THE NO.
AND MY A MY COUNCIL DOES NOT
REFLECT MY CITY LOOKS LIKE THEIR
POLICIES ARE OFTEN PRETTY
DISCRIMINATORY TO THE POPULATION
THAT'S INCLUDING ON HOUSING AND
HOW WE THINK ABOUT AFFORDABILITY
OR TWO IS BUILDING UP.
ALONG THE WAY AND WHEN I ASK HIM
ABOUT THOSE QUESTIONS ARE PUSHED
AND THEY TELL ME THOSE POOR
PEOPLE OR THOSE PEOPLE THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HER MEXICAN.
REALLY DON'T LIVE HERE AND THE
TO STRIVE IN TO GO TO OUR
SCHOOLS -- AND AND THEY THEY
LIVE ON THE OTHER SIDE IN WHICH
YOU COULD GET UP BETWEEN MY CITY
IN YOUR CITY.
HI AND I GET THAT ON A REGULAR
BASIS IN A COMMUNITY LIKE MINE
AND SO MAYBE THEY ARE FORCED TO
ASK THEMSELVES THE QUESTION A
LOOK AT THE REALITY THEY CAN
START THINKING OF BETTER MORE
INCLUSIVE POLICIES ALONG THE WAY
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
CALDERON.
THIS IS A MIDDLE FIFTEEN SIXTY
ONE BY SOMEONE NUMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA MOTION IS TO PASS REFER
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORRELL [inaudible]
BATES.
CABALLERO.
CAMARO AYE DORADO.
DORADO AYE MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK [inaudible]
ROTH.
OFF AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I WHO CASKEY.
CASSIE I TEND [inaudible] SEVEN
ZERO THE VOTERS SEVEN THE ZERO
WE WILL PUT IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU OKAY SO -- I SEE THE
SENATOR ROSS TO STEPPED OUT.
THE VOTE ON EVERYTHING OKAY AND
CENTER MCGUIRE WE DON'T KNOW OR
YEAH SO ON THE YES WE'RE GONNA
GO NOW -- EVEN THOUGH CENTER
THERE ALSO WAS TECHNICALLY LAST
TO ARRIVE WE'RE GONNA AWARD THE
REQUIRE WORD TO MISTER MCGUIRE
OVERRIDE THE ROLE.
BECAUSE HE'S NOT HERE AT THE
TIME WHEN YOU SHOULD BE.
OKAY.
OKAY WILL LIFT THE WILL OF THE
CALL STARTING WITH ITEM NUMBER.
ONE THIS IS A LITTLE SIXTY EIGHT
BY SOMEONE NUMBER TING THE
MOTION IS TO PASS IN REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES SENATOR ALSO.
DRAWS A AYE MCGUIRE.
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE NUMBER GUIDE NUMBER
I OKAY SIDE TENDER ZERO AND
WE'LL KEEP IT ON AND THEN WORK.
KEEP IT ON CALL -- ITEM THE AND
A SERVICE ANIMAL INTO COMING
BACK RECEIVE ON ISRAEL AND
EVERYTHING OKAY -- ITEM NUMBER --
FOR A. B..
THREE THIRTY EIGHT THIS IS ONLY
BILL THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY
SOMEONE NUMBER TO MOTIONS TO
PASS REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTERS.
DORADO AYE MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK.
SKINNER SKINNER AYE CASKEY.
SIXTY TWO A SIX TO TO KEEP AN ON
CALL -- ITEM FIVE WHEN WE DO THE
CONSENT AGENDA.
ON THE CONCERNED COUNTERS
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS FIVE SIX
AND ELEVEN SENATOR OTHER.
DORADO AYE MCGUIRE SKINNER.
SKINNER I WHO CASKEY.
CASKEY ICE. TEN TEN ZERO KEEP AN
ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN E. BEFORE.
THIRTY THIS IS A SOME ABLE FOR
THIRTY BY SOME NUMBER GALLAGHER
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
SENATOR.
DORADO AYE SKINNER.
I WITH HUSKY. TWENTY ZERO THREE
TEN ZERO KEEPING ON CALL -- ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY ONE THIS IS A
NUMBER SIX SEVENTY ONE BASED ON
THE NUMBER FRIEDMAN MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND WE'RE FOR
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR CABALLERO.
CAROL I DRAWS -- DRUGS SO I
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I WHO CASKEY.
OKAY THE VOTERS TEN ZERO WILL
PUT THE YES HE DID [inaudible]
YES.
OKAY SO SO TELL OKAY SO ON
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY ONE THE
VOTERS TEND TO ZERO AND THAT
BILL IS BALLOTS.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER.
NINE EIGHTY SIX NINETY FOUR THIS
IS A SYMBOL SIX TWENTY FOUR BY
SEVEN NUMBER IRWIN MOTIONS TO
PASS AND REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
VETERANS AFFAIRS.
SENATOR MORROW [inaudible]
BATES.
CABRERA I DORADO.
DRAWS AYE.
SKINNER.
INNER AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I CASKEY.
CASSIE I IN [inaudible]
ORDER -- YES HE'D.
OKAY SO THE VOTE ON EIGHTY SIX
NINETY FOUR IS HE TO ONE YES IT
TO ONE AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY NEXT ITEM NUMBER TEN AB.
EIGHT EIGHT ONE THIS IS A LEVEL
EIGHTY ONE BISON MEMBER BLOOM
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER
THE COMMITTEE IN GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
SENATOR BATES. EIGHT SNOW DORADO.
DORADO AYE MCGUIRE.
SKINNER.
NUMBER CORRECT NUMBER I SKINNER
I NINE TO ONE NINETY ONE WILL
KEEP THAT ON CALL -- ITEM NUMBER
ON A NUMBER TWELVE AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE THIS IS THE
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN NINETY NINE
BY SOMEONE UNDER BLOOM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SENATOR.
WELL I DON'T KNOW.
MORRELL I DON'T KNOW
[inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
TORONTO.
DORADO AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
A BURKE -- CASKEY.
THIS IS.
BUT I AM CLOSER TO GO.
CASSIE I SKINNER I WE'RE GOING
NUMBER I FIVE TWO OKAY SO IT'S
FIVE TO ONE AND WE WILL KEEP
THAT ON CALL -- NEXT ITEM
THIRTEEN AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THIS IS AN
ABLE FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER WICKS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
AND RE REFER.
RE REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
SENATOR CABALLERO.
CARRIER BY TORONTO.
TORONTO AYE MCGUIRE.
SKINNER.
SKINNER I AM.
NUMBER I YES AND THE SERIAL.
ZERO HE STATE ALL YES HE DID
OKAY -- OKAY ARE THE VOTE ON THE
VOTERS TEND TO ZERO AND FILLS
OUT.
BY NEXT ITEM.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN THIS IS THE MIDDLE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY SOME
REMEMBER TO MOTIONS YOU PASS AND
REFER THE COMMITTEE AND
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MORE LOCK ON BURKE [inaudible]
BECAUSE HE HI KATHY HI. SIXTY
TWO THEY'RE ALL SAYING.
YES [inaudible]
OKAY AHA.
THE THE VOTE IS SIXTY TWO THAT
BILL IS ALEX.
NEXT SEVEN FIFTEEN A. B..
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE THIS IS A
MEMBER FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE BY
SOMEONE NUMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
MOTIONS TO PASS IN REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SENATOR MORROW [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORE WALK.
THIS WEEK MCGUIRE.
OKAY SEVEN ZERO COUPON CALL.
NEXT ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE THIS IS AN
ABLE SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE BY
SUMMER BLOOM MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER THE COMMITTEE AND
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
CENTER DORADO.
DORADO AYE MCGUIRE.
CASKEY.
CASSIE I NINETY SIX SKINNER.
SKINNER I TEND TO THEIR ATTENDED
ZERO COUPON ON CALL -- HE WAS
THE SEVENTH AND GAME OR NOT AND
HE DIDN'T.
OKAY -- AND LASTLY A. B. SO --
SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX HE WAS AND I
WAS ON CALL.
AND SEVENTEEN AB.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE THIS IS AN
ABLE SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE BY
SOMEONE NUMBER TO MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER THE
COMMITTEE AND GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE.
SENATOR MORROW [inaudible]
BATES.
BATES NOW DORADO.
DORADO AYE MGUIRE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER FIVE THE CASKEY.
CASSIE I EIGHT TO ONE NINE THREE
TWO ONE AND WE'LL PUT THAT WILL
KEEP THAT ON CALL OKAY SO I
THINK OTHER THAN CENTER MCGUIRE
EVERYONE SHOULD BE.
GOOD TO GO [inaudible]
CLOSE.
IT WOULD HAVE STAFF
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
OKAY WELCOME BACK CENTER MCGUIRE
AND AND TECHNICALLY CENTER THERE
ALSO WAS THE LAST ONE TO ARRIVE
BUT I KNOW BUT I I EXERCISE
TEARS PROGRESSES I OVER ROAD
DIED AND AWARD YOU THE MONEY
MICHAEL CHOIR WERE CERTAIN
RESERVATIONS.
I DO NOT SEE HOW THAT'S POSSIBLE --
IN I THINK THAT YOU ARE NOW
STARTING TO BEEN THE RULES SERVE
TEARS A VERY POWERFUL AND SENATE.
I YEAH I DO WANNA OFFER --
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU ARE YOU
SEE DRAWS -- CORRECTED.
HEY THERE YOU GO.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA OPEN -- THE
ROLES ON THE ITEMS THAT REMAIN
OPEN -- ITEM NUMBER ONE AB.
SIXTY SIX THIS IS UNABLE SIXTY
EIGHT BY SOMEONE NUMBER CHIANG
MOTIONS YOU PASS IN REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
SENATOR BATES MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI MY LOOK.
OKAY THE VOTERS NINE TWO ZERO
AND THE BILL IS OUT -- ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB.
SIXTY NINE THIS IS AN ABLE SIXTY
NINE BY SMALL NUMBER TING THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI HELLO. ELEVEN ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB.
THREE THIRTY EIGHT THIS IS THE
MIDDLE THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY
SOMEONE NUMBER TWO MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
WHY ARE AYE MORLOCK?
CASKEY [inaudible] SEVENTY TWO
DELIVERED A SEVENTY TWO THE
BILLS OUT WILL NOW DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS FIVE SIX
AND ELEVEN SENATOR MCGUIRE.
ACQUIRE I VOTERS -- ELEVEN ZERO
THAT THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
APPROVED -- ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A
BEFORE.
THIRTY THIS IS ON THE BILL FOR
THIRTY BY SOME NUMBER GALLAGHER
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
[inaudible]
SENATOR CASKEY.
OKAY SO THOUGHT ATTENDED ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT.
NEXT TO THE ITEM.
TEN EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE THIS IS
THE ONLY BE EIGHTY ONE BY SOME
OF MY BLOOM THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFER THE COMMITTEE AND
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
[inaudible]
SENATOR REQUIRE [inaudible] NINE
THE VOTERS NINE THE ONE THAT
BILL IS OUT.
NEXT IS ITEM TWELVE A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE THIS IS A
NUMBER THIRTY NINETY NINE BY
SOMEONE NUMBER BLOOM MOTIONS TO
PASS REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
CARILLO.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE BARLACH. SIXTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX TO ONE OF BILLS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB.
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE THIS IS UNABLE
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE BY SOMEONE
NUMBER CRISTINA GARCIA MOTIONS
TO PASS -- REFER THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY SENATOR MORROW.
BATES MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MOORLACH.
HE TWO ZERO VOTERS EIGHT ZERO
THE BILLS OUT -- ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE THIS IS AN
ABLE TO SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE BY
SOME OF THE BLOOM MOTIONS TO
PASS -- REFER THE COMMITTING
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
[inaudible]
SENATE MCGUIRE.
A NO ONE SECOND CAN GIVE ME ONE
SECOND
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
THE DESERT ROSE TEN ZERO THE
BILLS OUT ITEM SEVENTEEN AB.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE THIS IS A
SIMPLE SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE BY
SOME NUBER TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER THE
COMMITTING GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATE MRO [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
YES THE VOTE IS A TWO ONE THAT
BILL IS OUT [inaudible]
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU EVERYONE -- TO ARE
CROWDED CHAMBER HERE -- THAT
COMPLETES OUR AGENDA TODAY AND
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED